all right and one hold on actually
record okay
and we both laugh flashpoint
ebox what's going on man oh not much
it's been um kind of an insane week
season five and started there's I'm
seven gonna warn you guys in advance
it's gonna be a long point to the max we
also talked about we were off for
Thanksgiving I had a little traveling
there and then they dropped just I knew
it was gonna happen and it was just like
drinking air hose all this stuff come in
annual past calendar and it's just like
holy crap so we got a lot to dig into
what is only a once again shout out the
but fuel this morning thank you guys and
then daddy fat stacks over there on ILP
get up to both you guys just names are
cracking me up this morning it's a
[ __ ] here for me nine o'clock on the
East Coast for you how's your morning
going sir we come obviously you already
know I've been transitioning over to the
master race wave artists hooks me up
with the fantastic suggestions and it's
truly been a pleasure so thank you sir I
have been enlightened times I've seen
the light of solid-state drives and 60
frames uncapped all this goodness that
I've been out of the PC market for over
eight years so it's just really good to
see how much of a dramatic jump this is
for somebody like me and um it's it's
real cool man so salute to my boy
bonta's help speck help price this Bing
out for me and I am in like cloud 11 I'd
I've got a chance to play much destiny
yet on PC but the little I've played Wow
so news flash you know I LP clan on Xbox
it will always be love it would always
be true but if you
living in the new style Oh may I'm movin
on up man I'm into penthouse now and you
know I got I gotta cheat myself to the
finer things in life right now
Oh for somebody who's been on console
for a while loved console huge even Xbox
1x player how does it feel when you step
into it for the what are the big things
you notice like what are the things that
you catch on PC because some people are
jumping in for the first time the game's
been free it's actually a good thing
like I mean if you're on console you've
never been a PC gamer just so what do
you feel like it adds to your experience
I think first off the bat is just the
pure speed is just the the fluidity and
the speed of the game it just feels like
a new game it's completely jarring at
first because go on for 30 frames per
second and don't get me wrong like I'm
Xbox one accident you know I'm doing
real good and shout out the Jay the Chad
what's that maybe I'm doing real good
but it's just like it is such a
disparity that it it you can't go back
you cannot see what you talk about you
can't like it I'll be lying to myself if
I sit there my yeah I'm going back it is
really a different game now as far as
the resolution that even impressed me
even more because remember I'm coming
from a xbox one x 4k HDR you know it
really looked great on a computer
monitor you know again IPS monitor
refresh rates extra high you know max
setting I am being inclusion know all
these things tehsil DUP and I have to
say it ain't 4k but man it look
fantastic with all these effects on one
so I'm seeing things that I didn't see
before just little money details just
doing the goal in the beginning the you
know that whole storyline you know d2
vanilla and man it is really really
impressive so yes console guys I'm
telling all my clan now if you got the
rig to run it man
just for 60 frames by itself alone is so
worth it so or did God do it that
welcome to the bright side of PC I mean
and honest it's just one of those things
not everybody's for it I mean you're
still playing controller on Mouse
instead of mouse and keyboard right I'm
stubborn I'm sorry I got my Xbox one
elite controller left I'm stubborn I'm
old-school like that's the other piece
and that can take like hey it looks
pretty controllers comfortable take some
time when you're just like running
around on patrol get that feel for that
mouse and keyboard and just literally
compare the weapons back and forth and
be like all right has this gun filled
with controller how does this gun feel
with mouse and keyboard because me like
I haven't played on controller for in a
while it just probably feel bad no
matter what but as it feels good to you
on controller see how it feels on a
mouse a keyboard or just literally like
pick up the controller you know pull the
trigger see how the recoil is use the
mouse and keyboard fight like click the
mouse just see how the differences are
I'll just gonna be curious no absolutely
absolutely I have to test it out in that
regard and see what all those
differences are so I would put things to
its paces but I will say this real quick
I know what its gonna be a long point
put on a pin we're gonna be here for a
while the funny thing is now that I'm a
king the Guardian again right oh stop
please blueberry out there yeah you
don't see I got the dirty clothes I'm
not even iced out I have no exotics now
I see the importance of xur and
Hawthorne let's just say that I will get
those are a little bit later but that's
exactly what they want there to be he is
for newer players he is for those things
that you might be missing from a
previous expansion that drop that just
didn't quite happen they're not trying
to be like hey let's just you know
funnel you all the exotics in this nice
beauty fashion they have to don't they
won't work behind them they want them
rare they want them to feel exotic and
people are like it's so funny I'll get
I'll do my serve video and stuff like
that and I don't know if it's gonna
change in a week or not we'll see but
there's a there's like I get more hate
on those videos and literally I don't
think it's for anything that I do people
just login me like ah he's got garbage
garbage again down voting it's like not
against me I'm pretty sure that's one of
the few or it's just like
they're just frustrated because but
that's not the purpose of xur like we've
kind of come to understand that so no
you're absolutely right it just made me
have an appreciation because again I'm
it's gonna be hard like I don't have
done the law I don't have sleeper all
these things I'm so used to so now it's
a matter of okay I have to get what I
can get to kind of get my foot footing
back to and to see what's up so III
recognize the imports I'll be looking
forward to your video later today it'll
be coming about three hours three and a
half let's get it man oh so we got a lot
of stuff to talk about as you guys saw
on the title card here we got season
five launched Tuesday we've got black
armory the full viaduct will cover that
either and at least just the notes maybe
watch little blips here and there
I've been calendar to discuss before we
even get to any of that stuff we were
out of town for Thanksgiving I was at
least made who traveling to send me some
pictures from a different stadium
shouting out to my Huskies out here so
we got some pinnacle weapons this is
season five and we've even got some
black armor yet so just weeks how you
doing man mmm so afraid so we got new
weapons to grind forward new quests to
work on things that look pretty cool
let's just jump in basically last week
squab was pretty quick came out on
Wednesday and they talked about three
weapons that's it and their pinnacles so
by pinnacle they mean in game long quest
grind got to do a lot of things if you
like PvP here's this one if you like
gambit here's this one I feel like PvE
here's this one so they actually have
one for each activity which is really
cool and we start with the vanguard
we've got ourselves a little fusion
rifle action you want to take this one
since actually you could jump in you can
jump in I'm a warm-up into it the next
one I really would have agreed so first
for the Vanguard this will be through
Zavala
it's a quest line we've got loaded
question so it's a high-impact fusion
rifle the unique purse is perk is
reservoir burst when the battery is full
so like if you fully reloaded your next
burst deals additional damage and causes
a muse to explode on death sounds kind
of cool I have it
I use fusion rifles that much here and
there I was working on just like some
art kills or something I had made in
green in my inventory
they still have some light they still
have a viable use sometimes I feel like
they're on that somewhat inconsistent
side to like just the the spread I wish
was just a little title tighter and
stuff like that so I want to get my
hands on this thing I mean if it's got a
good range good nice you know tight
spread on the bullets like so things
gonna be kind of a trucking if you get
one person to explode that actually
might be cool but this is this is built
for PvE not PvP so if you reload switch
over throw it a big burst with your
fusion rifle into a group enemies and
they'll exploding check out like 20
through all that's its purpose that is
its goal it's not as much like you know
might actually sound decent for like
some ad killing depending on what you're
fighting in gambit for saying I don't
know if this is gonna be like beast mode
for PvP personally just out feels yeah I
mean I agree I think it really makes
sense right because this is the vanguard
pinnacle weapon you know I'm cool with
that and to be honest you know I feel
like fusions are still not in the
greatest spot in PvE
so to see some type of spectacular this
with it it's really cool I'm digging
that you know the extra low beefiness to
the explosions and all that stuff for
our weapon is always nice you know I'm
saying so I'm cool with it man I just
got to get cracking from that questions
of Allah but I think this is definitely
definitely a nice you know a little
tribute weapon pinnacle weapon as a
start I'm cool with it yeah looks pretty
cool dry fling up a vanguard me want
some like snazzy pictures of these
things they are on be nuts check them
out so the quest works basically gonna
go to the ball or pick it up and you're
gonna have three pieces you got 500
fusion rifle kills in strikes or night
falls
so grab fusion rifles you like pick them
up find those perks whether it's
scavenger or reserves reload speed
dexterity all those things if you're
gonna be using this like dig through
your vault find those pieces on them
make it work 100 hour kills this is
actually gonna go pretty quick it can be
anything grenades abilities thunderlord
is a way to wipe this one out really
fast the long grind 40 strikes or
nightfalls
now
my little bit of advice for all of you
guys listening out there do your strikes
nightfalls are one thing that's just if
you're working on them or not but do
your strikes when it's heavyweight all
heavyweight on there bro art kills on
there just and just start record stuff
it's gonna be crazy art kills
thunderlord if you got it'll be great if
you had a like main ingredient art
fusion rifle yeah yeah those strikes
just the wiping amount quicker kill the
boss is really fast heavy weights gonna
be the way I grind so that kicks off
again today and then we'll be back on
Monday so look out for that heavy weight
like you know some people grind it out
the first day but if you want to just be
a little more efficient that's my two
cents at least this screams fund the
Lord to I mean to get them thousand
shout to Cory burns trying to get his
thousand yeah man that you all I'm just
visualizing it's done the Lord just
chained killing all those ads and just
racking up the kills so yeah it's gonna
be a fun guy I think you're on the money
with the what have you a two so there's
gonna be a fun little ride oh that's one
this one I think you might be the one to
want to talk about this this city is
this your next one
you looking for yeah well actually both
both but um yeah only gonna take it yeah
we got breakneck the precision
auto-rifle kinetic you know it's you
need perky's onslaught so the weapons
rate of fire increases as you stack
rampage that's pretty insane nice little
twist kind of gives you a rhetorics
twist but with rampage increased damage
so the plan was to make more pinnacle
weapons for a variety activities and not
just a crucible they think of something
that was fifty activity this is intended
to be a workhorse for gambit encounters
with killing large enemy numbers of
enemies very fast it's the name of the
game so I'm yeah man this thing they'd
added that to it you know he say
basically given that a legendary tier
effect like rampage on top of it like
they did but outlaw for desperado and
literally when I saw it that's what I
thought of it I don't know if you caught
the little V doc obviously you know I'm
saying but on this thing I mean he was
behind think was a Titan behind cover
and he was just destroying and I was
like wow I gotta have my hands on that
man so from a PvE thing this thing's
gonna be a beast you know basic pretty
much how to earn it
you get it from the drifter 500 Auto
rifle kills 100 Auto rifle multi kills
then you got 150 challenging enemies
defeated 40 gambit matches completed so
I got a question for you as far as a
your the solo guide guy you know you
know so uh what do you I had some
thoughts what do you think is gonna be
most efficient to get our hands on the
breakneck uh me I haven't touched auto
rifles that much in a while
I've even got to think of what would be
a good one to use Auto rifle multi kills
as well as one that's late yeah I don't
think about a good way to do that
because I mean things like risk runner
things like huckleberry those are ones
that I can like chain and keep firing
auto rifles I don't feel I have that
like that power that effect or that
speed of killing I'm sitting here and go
for it man I'm racking my brain honestly
we gotta get to the sweet business baby
oh okay that actually makes perfect
sense yeah we got a dust sweet business
so I was thinking about like dance I
said we figured we dust that bad boy off
and see how that goes just to you know
change stuff up but um this this is this
gonna be a fun little weapon to get man
I'm excited about this one yeah that
video you're talking about when you sit
in mind a rally barricade the lair
strike when like you have a thousand
enemies running at you I can't tell
there's anybody else in the room with
him but he's just just mowing them
because I mean rally barricade you
always have ammo and the firing speed of
this gun as it cranks up with rampage
and then the damage you get on top of
air it's just just just like a minigun
it looks crazy so if you can get in the
right position I think it's gonna be
cool it's just one of those where once
you get it running it'll be great
things like rally barricade Actium or
rig if it's not vacuum whirring audio
off rifles I can't remember yeah what is
he yeah yeah that's a yeah yeah so
anything to Luna faction boots
hunters are gonna be using to reload
jump a lot but it's like that continuous
just like crazy speed a lot of quick
you're gonna
learn through ammo fast so if you have
that way to keep the ammo coming in
that's gonna be crucial to let this
thing really put some work in but I'm
really looking forward to it kind of
like it I was like the little leather
strap looks like it's wrapped around the
barrel kind of cool yeah and then you
got the little drifter little chain on
it right yeah little drifter chain here
little icon there so got the stock in
the back looks cool I like it just looks
like Auto rifle from senior thirty-third
yes final piece somewhat controversial
we have the mountain top this is a
lightweight kinetic grenade launcher
it's the second one in the game first
one coming from the strike but yeah so
the unit perk is micro missiles weapon
fires in a straight line and as a
massively increased projectile speed so
not quite what I would consider like hit
scan for a weapon right but basically
picture like travel time of a fusion
rifle it's gonna be there pretty damn
fast so if you can hit them square on
good more power to you but if you're
looking at somebody's feet and you can
probably kill them before they jump like
that's the idea they're not like fire
rocket knew you might get away or take
less damage if they're on the ground and
you shoot it lighting it they're gonna
be quick so I've seen some people out
there were some videos that looks like
it could be interesting yeah I agree
what do you think I think this is a nice
little switch up you know obviously we
don't have many of this archetype so uh
unique micro missiles sounds cool you
know I'm saying so I'm very curious
about how that's gonna go um he says
addition to the above benefits to
project out instantly detonates on the
environment instead of bouncing like a
traditional game coordinating launcher
so that unless you have sticky grenade
selected so that's gonna be interesting
I like it I think this might be
something and for me as in crucible I
could actually see myself attaining it
because I'm a big um I believe part of
the as we go through the the perks of
attaining it I thought I remember seeing
um grenade launcher final blows yes so
as we go see as we go through that I'm
the imma play the game and so that's
part of my my repertoire so I can
definitely see myself getting this just
you know a fun weapon I think people
might be underrating it you know based
on the fact that it's a grenade launcher
you know me and most people don't tend
to use those in the crucible especially
I think this thing might sneak up on
people
big-time yeah I mean just the way if you
can cross map somebody if they're by a
wall if you can if you can go grenade
lunch or one shot Christ my pretty quick
with an explosion I mean it's got
potential if somebody's on a point you
can get up in the air and they're
standing there get them right at their
feet like grenade launchers taking the
bounce out and just like instant like
explosion it's gonna be pretty cool so I
know grenade launchers for me have
served me pretty well as of late I think
they got enough buffs the ammo is
starting to be a little more easy to
come by I mean if you throw a rally
barricade up and you dump 15 even edged
transit like you throw 15 of those into
something you're gonna dump some sweets
I mean grenade launchers are something I
was like oh no and then occasionally
sometimes I use them like I was even
just messing around with just testing
different weapons and shattered thrown
and for the ogor and I was like all
right skirt let's just see what edge
trains it does throw all the rally
barricade dump 15 rounds really fast
into the ogor and then manage the axiom
bolts and throw some damage in
afterwards it's literally about a third
of his damage so I mean if I'm soloing
it yeah it is three phases but it is
like dump it you know manage the axiom
bolts and rinse and repeat so mm-hmm
there's not bad like I was pretty pretty
down on grenade launchers for a little
while and they've you know I've
literally I use them all the time I mean
it's it's more effective because the way
I look at it is you know you get more
ammo you can one-shot if your placement
is good you know if you place a good and
the key part for me is on proc what is
it proximity I believe proximity air you
know and even with the nerf it's still
effective man so I listen I've been
running roughshod with play the game you
know a good edge transit role here in
there you know long that guy says long
as you speck out for the most part from
what you call a proximity if you get
that middle perk up the middle perk and
then regular perks I've been kind of
speck in rampages really nice if you get
that eighty anything would quit draw a
snapshot you know yeah that kind of flow
man you
you can start racking up soul yeah
people sleep that's that's my go-to
heavy way I can free up my exotic slot
for other things
yep so I mean grenade launchers get me
shot guys they're actually not too
shabby and this one isn't quite as
terrible to get so I mean it is still
the longest quest chain because it's
that pinnacle crucible activity but your
rink or reach step one get glory rank of
brave so you got to do that it's not
that far and what does that just drink
to basically yes yeah then you need 750
total points you can either do and this
is where I kind of all I'm I think some
people are like gonna be like it's not
quite as elite but giving people options
I think is okay mm-hmm 750 total points
in crucible urn grenade launcher final
blows now it's gonna take you 75 kills
in competitive or it's gonna take you a
lot more in non-competitive so it's
three points for non-competitive ten
points for competitive so definitely a
difference leaning towards competitive
then you've got rapidly defeat groups of
two or more players I think this is
gonna be the tough one
yeah double plays double plays to be
real I don't know about that one yeah I
didn't I didn't catch that that's a good
catch right there like that's tough how
many what so if you're going
non-competitive you get two points for
double plays you're gonna need a hundred
and then sub some subsequent kills after
double plays is one point so if you you
don't get a rocket launch or heavy pole
what do you get for maybe 5 mm not too
many you're gonna have to go BAM boom
you're gonna have to be quick so you're
literally gonna have to like hopefully
either be in control find people on
points but you like those signal shots
I'm gonna do it you're almost gonna it's
gonna be a weird use of like hoarding
your heavy ammo waiting for groups and
then praying you can kill more than one
it's like a weird so we're driving
competitive seems like even more yeah
because that that's so much more
question and question is this is not
grenade launcher double kill double
plays just double plays right I don't
know the way it reads rapidly defeat
groups of two or more opponents in okay
it's maybe not later they have
grenade-launcher up here maybe it's just
double plays in general which you've got
to be done supers and stuff will help
that a little bit so that's that's not
so bad oh just your launchers that might
be low no doubt Nova warp FTW okay
gotcha
see how it goes that's that that's that
whole path for me oh I'm good I'm good
no more I get to you through a wall uh
calculator trajectory metals I forget
what that is that like three on a clip
basically but if you do a
non-competitive you have to get a
hundred medals if you do it competitive
you've only got to get twenty so they're
definitely steering you towards
competitive to make those points a bit
more valuable so and then you get a
wrench fate reach fabled again same as
before just like Lunas house
so once you reach fabled you can come
down for the mountaintop and get your
grenade launcher but that's lit
literally it but those are the three big
ones for pinnacles he got strikes from
Zavala
we've got gambit from The Drifter in
this mountaintop grenade launcher given
us stuff to grind for I mean these are
the things that we want for neat and
grind like okay so I've got my stuff
what do we work on now worked on the
raid a little bit okay I'm gonna go work
on strikes this is actually the first
time I feel like I've actually have
incentive to run strikes ever yes cuz I
mean like getting powerful gear for that
one you may do that one or two or three
and then you're like I'm out I'm done I
don't know Kay this is like a time to
actually run 40 yeah there's there's
gonna be a few more people running
strikes for a bit so oh yeah that's
pretty cool but that is that is
basically what we missed last week guys
so wanted to catch you guys up on that
pinnacle weapons got some grinded to do
now I mean if you're gonna no life one
of these things you could probably get
like 40 matches in a day you might your
eyes might hurt after that yes right
about my two senses I mean yeah like
sweet business for gambit is definitely
probably gonna be a thing to consider
double auto rifles if you're unlike one
in each slot if you've got those so but
dig deep in your inventory see what you
got but if you're brand new to this game
on PC
well you gotta use what you got yeah man
absolutely
so what else is the picture now annual
pass we got more info in this dump and
I'd know what to talk about mmm we have
black armory
we've got Joker's wild and we've got
season of the redacted so big ol
discovery question mark here with this
guy we've got a lot of stuff about this
wallpaper is out there guys if you do
want to go check bungees Twitter those
wallpapers like pretty high res looks
pretty cool so if you want this one I'm
digging it so nice uh but before we get
into that we did actually get a patch
tuesday so patch 2.1 is here so we're
gonna go through these kind of piece by
piece I'm gonna let you kind of fill in
the pieces or you want to jump in yes
sir chaos reach I know this one's yours
yes yes let me get my hands ready we
stretch out alright one of my favorite
sunglasses so yeah it looks like they
fixed an issue in which multiple chaos
reach beings active at one time cause
their visual effects to merge to get a
shot to ask the cross he had a funny
joke with that you see he said he didn't
know mixing of the streams was an issue
with chaos so yeah we got that that we
got a fixed issue
beam's be able to penetrate friendly
banner shield so that's that's
interesting a fixed issue with it did
not damage taking bytes and the most
important bullet note changes they must
have her ve shall pay us reach
cancellation will come with destiny to
update two point one point one scheduled
for the fourth so that's a next week on
launch if I'm very happy it is good it
gets trash out discrete he said don't
cross the street haha yeah we now go
across the street baby we all here at
chaos we she's gonna get fixed to key
though he bounces for this is again
that's a very powerful super home it it
when you have geo mags especially insane
I've watched people do plague justice
gambit turns those where I'm able to
turn into a choke now I have to be
honest that they gonna have to be very
conservative because no warp as I'm
speaking from a warlock perspective
nova walk right now is extra beasty you
know I'm saying and if this thing allows
you to cut off at super cut off and
you're just getting geomatics and then
you topping it back off again this could
get broken so I think they're gonna go
conservative knowing bungee and I'm
saying but I'm just glad to see that the
functionality on some level because to
go back to it from you know stopping a
super at eighty percent and then you
know go all the way down to almost don't
think they're gonna do that I remember
previously when they were talking about
they're like it's being efficient with
your cut off like you got to use some if
you cut it off too early you're gonna
lose a lot but if you cut it off late
you'll actually save some so it's that
manage of like you might say like a
quarter of your super but it is a
quarter of your super but like if you
want to melt a mini like mini-boss or a
couple majors or real quick melt them
down turn it off save a quarter jump
back into a little quicker so you
actually have more options to like well
I don't want to use it on these guys but
this one doesn't seem more a big enough
to use you can get more uses out of it
especially running activities so I think
it's gonna be I think they've tried to
balance that in previous stuff they
talked about so we'll see of course they
may have missed it but she'll track I'll
shout out to you gommi in your chat he
says he got geomat yesterday I'm jealous
and he said it feels like double the
duration yeah it's stupid I've watched
that just the primeval health on the
other team goodness I'm like oh it is so
no more
fixed an issue with Nova works sometimes
fail to detonate on release it's kind of
a big deal yeah you ever noticed or not
really you know what's funny once in a
while I have noticed it yeah okay yeah
it's how you like hold on I know I get
needed on like what's going on this
guy's not dead so yeah it glitches I
would say about 10% of the time for the
most most effective but I've seen an
yeah Sentinel just initially where the
shields would actually like lose energy
when guarding near friends so it was
kind of a weird like friendly firing
situation spectral blades got a big buff
I know increase the reliability of melee
attacks and the effectiveness of the
stealth so like stealth is like not
gonna pull as much energy I'm seeing
people definitely put in some work with
spectral blades so it got a decent buff
burning Maul and that
changed a couple of these burning Maul
and thunder crash to alleviate motion
sickness I guess they were a little
crazy on camera effects so those are
taken care of a couple exotic armor
tweaks
just kind of balancing like Ursa furiosa
so that super gain from guarding is more
consistent between PvE and PvP because
PvP was broken too some people opt in
aspects not increasing melee range on
various things we've got action boosts
so fix do ship in which buffs granted by
Luna faction boost would last for only
15 and seconds instead of oil ratings
instead of 30 so random little tweaks
are fixing with exotics yah Ward's law
like fully got like switched yeah yeah
this is weird because I forgot the
curated on mean even kind of the charm
which no one will get anymore I guess
yeah so triple tap is replaced with
feeding frenzy now which is actually the
thing on machine guns which is weird mhm
and then you got four times the charm
replaced with Zen moment which feels
like kind of a slap in the face for that
guy yeah yeah like that so it has bullet
contrails I guess that's the trails
behind it intrinsic perk text on the
wardens law to distinguish it from
aggressive bullet sidearms so still
gonna be that like to tap little hand
cannon but it feels like it kind of got
a hit in the face and something I never
thought was like I never heard about
wardens law being like all this is the
best thing in the game like something
that was like just kind of in the mid
range feel is like it just got its knees
taken out from underneath it's one of
those that's always always kind of
bugged me a little I know I know why the
damage is there but I still think Scout
rifles don't have enough high impact
scout rifle damage increased by one
point eight seven percent it's a very
specific amount which is weird but they
say basically as possible if you were
running high resilience to survive three
head shots from the high impact scout at
this point you can three head shots from
high impact will kill you no matter your
resilience so basically I guess what
they were going for yeah got a stop it
for a second this is the first time I
believe they've mentioned high impact in
conjunction with PvP because before it
was only specific damage to PvE
mentioned you know increase so this is
the first time I'm seeing you know like
as far as business other you know other
guardians for the first time in
reference to highs
high-impact hoes yeah I mean it's like I
feel like they need to talk about him a
little more there's no couple archetypes
that need some love but yeah
specifically like a class like
specifically high impact Scouts versus
PvP like this is a very specific change
so they go on a little deep on the data
their shotguns this is uh gonna change
some people's thoughts here rapid-fire
frame shotguns now increase the reload
of all shotgun shells when empty which
actually kind of like that if you dump
it out fast you can't actually get it
back quicker on the other side yes it
definitely is gonna be a French barrel
which is what you guys all know and love
from your I Colo shotgun French barrel
now deactivates after three shots
updated to reflect new behavior also fix
an era where was called out whatever so
now instead of your eight shots getting
your trench barrel perk you know and
being able to continually unload like
Luna faction you get three shots and
then you're back in a normal damage
range or damage amount so what do you
think that does what do you feel let's
be honest y'all it had to happen this is
probably one and I'm not a nerf guy like
Bungie calls nerf crazy but this is one
nerf that had to happen because the
reality is I've said it many flashpoints
you know you know my loadout
you know is either that whatever my
favorite kinetic was escalation protocol
shotgun and energy and sleeper and you
know have you I was just redundant with
that build it was just nothing more
effective so at some point you have to
encourage variety now I still don't feel
it's that bad I mean you're still
getting the three shots with the you
know the trench barrel you know you're
probably not gonna be able to melt
everything like you did before but this
is gonna it's gonna promote diversity in
that slot that weapon is too dominant in
that slide the way you guys give me crap
about sleeper and gambit this thing was
a jack-of-all-trades in everything like
I've been even in the crucible that I
closed was putting in work now granted
transmitter I had no effect there but um
you know it's just one of those things
that it was just so
overwhelmingly better than anything else
in the slot now I can dust off my eagle
age-old bond you know now you can you
know get you trust out a little bit you
know I'm saying like it's gonna you know
promote some diversity and it's needed
I'm not a nerf guy but this is one that
it was just like you know just a slight
little thing and booth boost every
couple of things up in the energy slot
and I'm cool but what do you think what
did you did you feel I didn't need to do
it like where you at with the whole man
I'm with you it and I forgive just it's
like as you said you felt like if you
weren't using that gun you were missing
out and there's a point where we like
different things they're gonna have
different benefits and nerfing something
they typically don't want to do but when
something is so dominant to a point of
like you feel like you can't use
anything else
mmm you can't break a whole weapon slot
and I think this is a way to like if you
want to run it you're still gonna get
three out of eight shots you just don't
want to run a full-auto shotgun you're
gonna dump a lot of damage it's just not
gonna be a broken level of damage so you
want to run something else you can and
honestly I know people are gonna hate it
people are gonna be sad about this one
cuz it's like oh this is my go-to and
it's like yeah it's everyone's go-to
weapons you pick up you don't even look
at them or consider them and especially
with you know black armory coming out
and they want to make more things viable
they want more things to be an option so
it it as you said it had to happen
it needed some way to bring it in check
and I think this is a way that if you
want to dump your you know 18 shots your
first three are gonna get you a lot of
damage it's still shotgun gonna hit
pretty hard you're just not gonna do as
much know as you said it's the decent
shotgun but it's just not kind of broken
beyond all belief at this point yeah and
I'm saying shout out to them for making
the decision and you know like I said I
mean I know some people were really hurt
behind it
shout out to egami to 2004 Nia Chad said
he saw it happening he said basically it
was like fate meant forsaken Mehta was
basically fate bringer black hammer and
galley days yeah it was like whatever
your best kinetic was EP shotgun sleep
you will you had everything covered you
know I mean now you got to think about
that loadout and that's what we
have to do and it's still good you're
still getting you still gonna be bees
it's not gonna be you know what
everybody's gonna promote some diversity
in the any energy slap so I'm with it
yep submachine guns slight increase
arrange machine guns slight increased
accuracy got a couple exotic changes
Prometheus lens got a little boost to
damage marred light could over penetrate
banner shields which is weird mmm-hmm
well meant amore this is kind of a I'm
okay with it because the momentum or
ease from six down to five bullets but
when you get it you don't have to have
all of them in momentum port momentum
Mori bullets gone you just reload the
perk so like they dropped one but show
honestly probably have it more
frequently anyway so that one seems like
kind of a weird switch but you know
you'll have it won't you I think it's uh
you know six of one half dozen of
another mmm-hmm
whole bunch other fixes in here if you
guys want to read them I'm not gonna go
through every single one of these they
just kind of polished some things up and
change some things they're four basic
changes crucible top one I was very
excited to see this mayhem will return
there is a face of v6 rotating playlists
with scoring support or new forsaken
supers thank you I have been waiting for
mayhem I cannot honestly fathom how much
insanity is gonna be going on in there
because you're gonna have chaos reach
beams and and then there's gonna be some
invisible spectral blades that go stabs
everybody in the back like honestly
mayhem play it's the fun mode that I
wish was in there all the time because
sometimes I just want to burn off steam
these constant space magic is like an
amazing way to do it
facts facts and Loki that's what saved I
would say saved but it really helped
reinvigorate I think that's one bungee
started to get back on track when they
kind of they basically um put it back in
the playlist during on the vanilla d2
crucible days and I thought that was a
great great move because at the end of
the day they realize yo forget balance
from it let's just have some mindless
fun like the way ya a crucible was
structured in a beginning it was just
such a 4v4 competitor
sweaty like people got tired of it
number the time to kill was too high it
was so much things that were wrong at
that time and in my opinion them putting
mayhem at that they started to get a
feel of what made their game fun again
and I'm so glad to see it come back cuz
to be on a full disclosure you know I
lived in crucible and even in its
current state when you play quick play
quick play in its in its hole in the in
term itself should just be quick fun
getting it and that's it you know and
what this thing was like was it was just
way too sweaty so this that's good to
see man I I'm very happy that uh
Mayhem's coming back huge fan of me yeah
I can't wait honestly I just wish it was
one of those things that was in the
quick play like rotation like play kick
play control play clash oh no one showed
up speaking of what I'll show up in
quick play lockdown and showdown will
return as rotating playlists have been
added to private matches
I played a lockdown match just in
quickly it just showed up
so lockdown that's kind of interesting
because it's like control but it's based
in rounds and you kind of like it's your
time that you hold the points but if you
go for a triple cap rounds over mm-hmm
oh that was actually kind of cool and
actually had some luck in there so I won
my two games I played knows like I'm out
two wins and ran but honestly the two
games that I played I feel like I had
like an insane amount of kills from
everybody else I'm like am I in a weird
matchmaking so I'm like I'm not amazing
curse well never gonna claim to be I
have moments where I'll like go off for
a game and then I'll get humbled by the
next game so it's like I'm all over the
place mm-hmm but the two games I played
I felt like I was playing against
blueberries or something because I had
like twice the kills of everybody else I
was like you know ever he's like 15 16
and I'm sitting there was like 30 kills
I'm like what happened I'm not that I
was like really me it is not me it's
like sometimes I'll run with my brother
and just his you know crucible ranking
I'm sure it's just probably not that
high and I'll play with him I'm like oh
I get to have a little fun in here now
and just go tear some heavy Bluff and
then I'll go back and play by myself and
be like oh yeah I still suck that far so
I didn't skill base trust me I feel it
sometimes for sure absolutely absolutely
but it was kind of cool just like it is
still kind of annoying to me though that
everything is still based on like it's
some variation of control like I'm
missing the objective mode still I want
like really want capture the flag or
even something I want I want some object
like the hill like can you imagine king
Hill on most any other Maps works just
like one point hold it for a little
while okay now it moves huge image spawn
points and just like you're like
clashing over that one area of
importance because if it's three you
split up but that holding at one point
like you got to stand in there to hold
your points like it makes it tough it
would change up like different supers
you'd use for the bubble you'd have like
rally barricades more losing your Wells
more stuff like that would play give you
a reason to kind of run a little
different I'm with you man
scorched has been added to private
matches I love that because that was
just crazy
that's your baby I was just like it was
fun it was another one of those stupid
phone ones everyone as the Scorch gain
and explode things and it's actually
harder than it seems because if you're
jumping in the air it's hard to direct
hit some of those things so yeah that's
entertaining Shaq's has new lines for
Christmas always crazy he says some new
stuff to me recently he said it I went
off and he would just fly he started
naming all these warlock terms he was
like something of the barracks ik fire
you know something of the order I Cora
will be I was like yeah let's go there's
always cool but they do that with him
with salad I love it I love those little
touch and to take with destiny first
debut I thought it was the weirdest
thing
and now I've turned into loving that in
any type of competitive or PvP so I
think that's pretty cool nice they have
more medals in there which I think what
you're literally talking about machine
guns are a thing now they've gotten a
couple gold tier medals so those are new
ones for people to go hunting for iron
banner now Awards unique iron banner
themed medals so just kind of more
Awards those tweaks and stuff like that
overall ranks gotta change so now
they're subdivided into the three ranks
similar to game but so you get your like
you know fabled one two and three stuff
like that's going to be in there
valor and glory will not subdivide the
legend rank valor does not require
players to win at legend which is I
don't know if that's a tweak or not but
maybe a minor one shacks has a new
rotation of items available for direct
purchase so he'll have like I think he's
got boots is what he started with I
don't have a changes on that daily or
weekly but he's gonna have some stuff in
there as well and then that pinnacle
weapon will be in his inventory to work
on so you start the quest for the
crucible grenade launcher through shacks
so if you want to go there mmm nice for
gambit we've got adjust that infamy rank
rewards to be kind of a better match for
valor and glory you get your sub
division ranks things like that and then
of course you've got just the fact that
the bounties now give you double infamy
so every bounty that was Christine's now
30 50 is 100 150 s 300 they'll give you
more so the bounties have a little more
weight to them actually insane were to
go pick them up other than that there is
a new rotating bounty in there for
killing primeval envoys thank you that's
just one of those things that's not this
is where is like Bungie makes really
cool things but for the newbies who late
they need the tutorial in there they
need you to like hey you've played a
match of game I think I said this last
time you come back out you later when
the prime needle spawns killing these
envoys the little Wizards they spawn
with they will give you a boost to
damage on the prime evil and watch the
ads if you are like when you get to
round 2 or what is this like go and
explain those pieces sometimes they'll
do like the pop up screen do that for
like 2 or 3 click throughs like for new
people playing game and be like if you
know what it is cool if you want to know
all the mechanics that'd be a great way
to explain in just like 3 or 4 pictures
and again absolutely I have not played
gambit that much to know how to be
catching mechanics have you touched it
yet um I have not um I've definitely
hold on a second we got the cop coming
yeah so kognito got a new mic so I know
he's muting there right now so joys of
sirens coming through loud and clear but
once those pass by he'll come back but
basically what happened if you haven't
seen catch up mechanics have changed the
trailing team will now only get one
bonus stack and they will not get like
four
for example the time before the Stax
kicks in has been increased so you
actually takes longer for them to come
in which is kind of interesting so like
the longer you've you got your primeval
buff some of those stacks just come in
time so 22 seconds now 32 so like you
have more time to invade you have more
time for that tug of war to go back and
forth mm-hmm and it said Prime Evils
will hard being less often to reduce
stunlock against highly coordinated
teams I'm not sure what they mean there
I'm kind of confused you know what that
means yeah let me get to it repeat the
sentence break this thing down man
primeval little hard paint less often to
reduced unlocking and highly coordinated
easy yeah I'm not sure I remember son I
think let's fall out of these guys it
has some strat and they were mentioning
hard ping so the vibe I got there is so
I don't wanna say it's an exploit but um
there is something in play that guys
would do and then it would kind of like
de-facto
get to this point when you can um if you
time things perfectly that you can
actually melt a boss like really super
fast I'm thinking that's part of the
mechanic but um you know listen I like
the fact that they're addressing gambit
you don't say in any sense you know
they're still tweaking it the catch it
with mechanics have definitely got a
little weird because it was definitely I
did feel at some point it was favoring
the losing team that's not necessarily
getting the objective to stay in it and
just always feel so you know I'm with
the changes let's see how it plays out
we obviously know we in the season of
the drifter game is gonna get expanded
upon even more it's a great mode they
still got to find that happy spot I
still don't think it's like in a
terrible spot right now but I think
they're still trying to find that
balance so I'm with it man let's see
what it is and as far as that hard ping
thing I do remember it was kind of like
a coordinated time team effort that can
really melt and give another team an
advantage so good to see that they
acknowledge it yeah you got me saying
actually when you tether both envoys it
counts as killing them so that may be a
way to kind of get that extra like bonus
or stagger or something like that that
tether may be doing something
and also wonder if it's just talking
about almost just the stagger of the
primeval as well so could be very well
things but just sounds like I mean if
you go crazy coordinated your still
might be able to melt I mean Geo mags is
just a crazy with melting point but just
sounds like it's gonna give just the
teams that are really coordinated a
little more effort to work through maybe
not that much but maybe just a little
bit more you know time for somebody to
come in and maybe not watch that boss
damage go from 100% to zero and I can
tell you random people and we're like oh
let's get ready okay let's Garrity and
it's over I'm like what I just blinked
like yeah so like just the the Fate the
speed that those bosses go down is nuts
mm-hmm clan bounties make sure you guys
are doing those cuz it is a new season
for clans so usury set all that stuff
out mm-hmm uh items basic patches here
I'm not gonna go through I don't think
there's too much in detail and then
random things for PC so nothing nothing
too much here as we follow through the
rest of this these are just patch notes
if you guys want to get into the
nitty-gritty read the bottom part of
this I'm not gonna bore you guys with
those mm-hmm
now on Bart let's get so wait it's a
little yeah let's get to it so before we
go into this thing yes sir
how you feeling after watching this
thing I felt good I feel good but
actually I should ask you your feeling
because the reality is let's keep it
really you were very concerned want him
just info I don't see I'm not gonna let
you all do it let me do this what I kept
saying I want info I want info I don't
know what's going on I want info a
lovely pool of abundance which she
bought is history I'm listening artist
which this man continued for like for
the last two weeks to say hey what is
going on
we've got no information which he was
right I'm not gonna say he was wrong for
feeling concerned but it was one of
those things that I'm like you know he
is coming I said it's like you know he's
gonna be a different cycle because the
vibe and which I wish I think I was
right in a sense that you know
so used to the traditional season pass
mode where's that big splash you know a
big promo cycle for about two to three
weeks prior and this seems to be that
whole different approach which I did say
with annual pass which is like all this
specific content and now it's looking
you know day and date you got fish you
got that you got this you got that so on
yeah man it's it's real it's real
interesting um after seeing the video to
your question so good man
it felt good it felt it felt like um how
I felt when and I said this before then
it doesn't get enough credit warmind
woman set the tone in my opinion as far
as you know consistent content and then
for second just took it to the next
level of consistent difficult shake
attainable things and stuff like that
and thing things to do each week and I
just felt like okay we're gonna get that
we got some cool things coming back
we'll get more into deeper deeper into
those things that are coming back and
we'll get deeper into lore stuff as well
but overall I felt solid am I looking
for forsaking levels probably not but I
do feel there's a lot packed in here so
um it's gonna be curious to see so let's
get it back to you you know now that
you've watched that video you've had a
chance to digest where's your mindset
are you relieved are you were yet with
this couple you guys tuning in for me I
am I'm pretty positive about all that
I've seen so far I like little little
tidbits of information that if you don't
like you know watch this thing like four
times you may have missed just in quick
passing little things about like new
perks coming the in-game be missing the
quote that they literally said of
forsaken was a cam they wanted it not to
be a campaign with an in-game but an
endgame with a campaign that basically
means the focus is on the in-game
campaign is gonna get you through and
honestly like this is one of those
things people give Call of Duty a lot of
crap about
where is 95% near times played if you
play that game for any extended period
of time at all it's always in PvP so
it's a multiplayer or
for something like this where's our time
spin you're gonna do those missions once
or if you play your characters three
times and then you're gonna be spending
time on the in-game the grind the now
you know your pinnacle weapons stuff
like that and that's what they're giving
us more of so there may be less story
there is some story in here which I'm
not going to go into deep uh but I mean
probably some story out the silo giant
spoiler piece towards the end of this we
will give you a huge huge earning when
that yes but just the fact that they've
got a plan for more in-game activities
more stuff for us to do talking about
matchmaking mods perks stuff we kept
literally discussing over the past
couple of weeks most of it's in there
it's like they've been they they know
what we want they know the grind needs
to have legs and a reason and they kind
of phrase it pretty funny they don't
want one big Thanksgiving feast and then
you take your nap and you go play the
games they want that they want that long
term that spread that continuous drip
feed of stuff to do fans I mean from
what I can tell and this is me like 35
bucks on a and you'll pass and I bought
the combination so for me it's actually
only 30 like it sounds like I mean I
already put I don't know thousands of
hours in the damn destiny games anyway
it's worth every penny to me and
honestly what it looks like from what I
can see I can hopefully happily say yeah
go spend your 30 bucks if you enjoy this
game you don't have to like no life the
things first off enjoy them and say like
in February when anthem comes out take a
little break go play in them it's gonna
be PvE game there may get to a point
where you like you know slow down on
stuff to do there and turn back around
jump back in for what comes out come
back for a week I mean they're gonna
give you stuff to come back and forth to
which I think is gonna be the biggest
key of like hey this might be my thing I
play on Tuesday or Wednesday but then I
turn around it may be you know anthem
has something going on over here or a
division of something going on over here
they're doing its where you've always
got a reason to potentially come back
and they're gonna make you like test and
see like hey how how much do you have to
do in these other games right let me let
me break that down even further down
shout to the dude in the Cheka senior
bro yo you please watch stars Tower talk
man love this I swear we got to get you
on the show bro I know you probably
weren't seriously I'm surprised we
haven't actually dude and piccolo toes
of my gosh at our talk they have a great
destiny podcast kind of to man format
like got like we do and Greg good dies
and he made a comment he said I love the
folks on the end game that's what I was
trying to say with warm I like war mine
brought the end game back and then he
was saying that the celebrate expansions
I've been taking him forsaken leave the
story German expansions to the full
update content activities should be the
focus between and he's right and the
thing about it is Forsaken was in such a
good place that it really made cuz the
old destiny style of DLCs like to do the
saying it's like you know you blaze it
out you have that chunk and then like
that effect Thanksgiving feast your fat
alright I'm done I'm gonna face our
mouths I got everything done but this
steady drip feed and these are still
good chunks it's like this always
something to come back with so for
saying it was probably the most I've
played destiny in forever like I just
couldn't stop you know one week it's
test and it shattered thrown that it's
that and it it's just something always
going on and I feel that Bungie has got
it now like they're in pocket now like
they know yo this is what they want like
they finally I think they're they're you
know I mean so I'm on it man I think
this is a good looking at you know this
calendar you know what we see in already
you know when we get into the dates and
stuff like that you know I'm very
curious you know I'm saying it's that
shout-out to silent shadow yeah they
finally hit that sweet spot that I
completely agreed he said hard after you
I wish you man I'm which yeah I think
they them and its act for the first time
I felt confident yeah I was like yo I
don't I think we're okay I think we're
okay you know and that that was
ultimately what the vid I did for me
yeah um so without playing the whole
thing for you guys I'm just gonna go
through and kind of talk about points I
went through and kind of pulled him out
basically so I mean they basically
phrased it this way they're no longer
doing DLCs they're note
longer doing those big campaigns and
even the dude said it right leave the
story stuff they're gonna do that for
your big annuals the big pieces of like
September drops that's gonna change your
story that's gonna make your progression
into the next like giant evil in the
world that we're probably going to fight
they're going to give us content of
stuff to do activities different ways to
drive all that stuff's gonna be coming
so seasons they have their free stuff
annual pass they're gonna and I'll add
on more in-game activities more and more
things for us to do to get that grind
going good stuff first off power camp
going up to 650 what do you think you
think it's enough um you know obviously
50 always seems small for guys like I
said but you know at the end of the day
it's gonna be more about the content the
number that I don't care about that as
much as I used to now like it's more
about what's being offered in that I'm
excited about um dude has a question for
us he says if I got a course he said
regarding that calendar because strike
missions have been shoehorned in as
campaign missions how do you think
they'll add new strikes if at all that's
a good question but you feel ah good
question actually if we're getting
strikes I honestly don't know if we are
it's kind of an interesting like I don't
I haven't seen a mention of those
specifically we've got we'll get to it
like the forges the you know the other
bigger activities but I honestly don't
know if I've seen strikes and that's
kind of one of those things I feel like
we need yeah we do need one or two like
it might not have to be a ton but if
there's a couple more in the rotation I
mean if you're gonna have these Vanguard
pinnacle activities and I'm gonna spend
my time and strikes it will get old
playing like the same I mean there's 14
there's not a decent there's a decent
amount of strikes but I mean even it's
gotta be like one or two or even release
like release one at the start of a you
know a season and release one in the
middle like you can spread them out over
time I think strikes are one of those
things they can't just like let fall off
to the wayside and time September
because that's gonna be really weird if
they do yeah I think that's the small
misstep if we're gonna say if we're
gonna nitpick yeah they're not yet
yeah I agree I'm so for the 50 power cap
will kind of get to a little bit later
blood soft cap still 500 yeah you are
600 it's still gonna be powerful engrams
in-game content is your way to grind up
will kind of get to other level
requirements and stuff like that but I
mean yeah you're not gonna get a soft
cap a little bit higher there's a couple
tweaks to help with you know getting up
to about 550 I think they're gonna give
some boosts but if you're up to 600 now
you're gonna be going real slow so I
think literally just said the same thing
I did so yeah it's gonna be a slower
grind to get to 650 which again it's
kind of what we're going for if we get
you know get everything too fast and too
quick we lose our reason to grind some
okay
also they mentioned forges which are the
new thing for black armory and we'll get
into a bit more detail on those but
basically they're a horde mode based
experience they've got waves of enemies
that you have to keep fighting through
so it's really horde mode trying to
defend this thing and you actually turn
into the black spent on this one I kind
of like the way they describe it forges
are gonna be something where you've got
waves of activities you're getting
components to build these weapons that
you're trying to do and then you
actually have to go put the weapons into
the Forge defend it while it sounds like
it's doing this thing and I mean you're
gonna be the new title for this
expansion is blacksmith you're literally
made you are the blacksmith you are
making the weapons so what do you think
about that what do you how what do you
feel in these four just so far from the
little blips we kind of get from the
villain I'm gonna suck up a horde well
no if I told you that like horde mode
first of all co-op in general that's why
destiny just appeals to me on a
fundamental level but horde mode dude
like that's my thing I love setting up
shop setting getting into defensive
stances and and hunkering down so now
you're throwing this whole Forge
mechanic on stuff I'm super excited and
the most important thing is matchmaking
baby oh let's go you know I got it I had
to do it because at the end of the day
it's like you know great activity
escalation protocol you know I'm saying
no matchmaking like I'm so glad they
enjoyed that is gonna
to the next level and if there's enough
to do and that like I the the main thing
that problem that we have with blonde
well was also specific rewards in said
activity right now we're forging in
doing stuff there so I'm cool I am cool
with all of this yeah man this this
sounds like this this might be the mole
for me so I'm very high to put that to
its paces yeah so we got a new title
you've got your forges you've got the
black armory of course they talked about
if you guys have seen from you know the
giant picture on the thumbnail this is a
2-1 she is the kind of one who runs the
black armory and she's not too much a
fan of guardians right now literally the
little clip we get is you you don't
belong here she doesn't trust guardians
and but she does need our help they said
they've been trying to keep these
weapons away from the vanguard because
they don't trust them with them so but
at this point I guess there's been
enough of a shift or something's happen
because they need our help to go out
into the world and refire these forges
so that's gonna be there's gonna be some
little campaign story or incentive to go
do these things there's gonna be some
maybe voice over something going on so
it's not gonna be like full 12 mission
campaign or anything like forsaken but
it's probably gonna be a few or maybe
one intro for each of the forges there's
four of them I think so you've got quite
a bit to do and there's gonna be a
little tie in to bringing this new
faction and bringing the lore in and I
think it's pretty cool
so side note what do you think happens
with faction rally in calendar but we
can they are not mentioned at that in
the Oh game fine
counter a little later but there are two
things not on there one faction rallies
now they want those things tweaked until
they like them figure out what they do
with them make them actually serve a
proper purpose the other one you want to
say it because I know you know what I'm
talking about man there you go
where's Osiris I I don't want the crazy
guy
if mr. ban it's the nine boy I mean
listen I know they're working on it but
uh
didn't mention I believe I did see it in
our Twitter post I'm gonna say from
Cosmo Cosmo yeah
but damage one those guys but um yeah I
mean I lo keem it's fractured I want my
new monarchy Shady's I'm running low I'm
running low on that red and gold
goodness man I can pull them out now you
have a collection I don't know I'm just
joking but jokes aside it's just like
you know I like the concept of it and
you know in a real talk though for the
real reason why I'm like what's going on
how how people ever supposed to get
those catalysts again yeah I mean if
nothing else they need to be attached or
thrown out in the wild because yeah it's
like SunShot sweet business which
literally I remember grind it for that
one which may be more beneficial now
Oh graviton yeah yeah which has pretty
much fallen off I haven't used that
thing in ages so low kiosks I used it
that was the last thing I did before on
console before I guess switch over it's
still good man it's just not fast as
like bygones and stuff like that yeah
you yeah
shout out today dude you're gonna stop
this new monarchy slander and he's
ranking he said dead orbit is good right
drag drag is greater than future okay I
see we dog yeah pretty much dead orbit
is good and everything else is a you
know dumpster fire links to the drag so
dead all be there bunch of deserters you
guys are deserted you guys want to get
when it going gets rough you whatever
run jumping a Shh I would tell me that
we do some dead all but slander right
quick you guys live at their own ready
at the airport on a tarmac I love you
dude so what else we got
so there are three families involved in
the black armory there's a point in the
viaduct they actually kind of show their
banners which look really cool their
each of the symbols you guys will see if
it's actually on the chest of
right here you'll see these little
symbols these are actually the three
little factions on the chest of 801 so
those are gonna be the ones can I have
their involvement the weapons kind of
have different fields and designs and
things like that so those are gonna be
cool
now small spoiler warning right now
token in here as well for weapons that
we got coming mm-hmm
you guys want to hear them let's go uh
no no okay so we have three main ones
that we know of one exotic quest which
we'll get to a little bit later but from
black armory there are different names
to the forges and we can actually
probably scroll down to see this a
little better it will come back up don't
worry so you got the Ville under forge
but go fanon forge the is a Nami Forge
and I don't know what niobe Labs is I'm
guessing that's the fourth one but that
one is not listed as a Forge that's why
I don't know if it's gonna be a little
different but it still looks similar so
I'm sure it is one of them one of the
guns specifically is like Izanami that's
the sniper rifle that you guys have seen
everywhere it's literally this thing
that she is holding now the way this
works it's a sniper rifle but there is a
special reload I don't know how the
functionality on it works it puts all
four bullets of the clip into one
special round and it's so powerful it
can body shot in PvP and it's got damage
that they say will keep up with sleeper
and whisper in that if for PvE beast so
I don't know why how what numbers this
thing is gonna have when you smash all
those together but it's gonna be crazy
east love it love it that's very unique
like the concept I'm assuming you
probably would be charged down the
reload button almost like a borealis or
Harley I'll hold it down for a little
bit yeah I do that kind of do some
animation to charge it that shot in
there so bees and I like the fact that
they're not they're unafraid to put
things on that level right because we
know you know did pinnacle chase was
obviously sleeper I mean I sleeper
everybody this is gonna be a heavy
device the vibe I'm getting mad
Wilhelm scream says he had number one on
his list until unless icebreaker comes
back to wait a little while on that one
scream nobody I think we've got data
miners saying I'd like to hear about
data miners don't ruin
don't ruin things yeah I said nothing I
said nothing yeah but yeah that's one of
the cool ones we've also got I don't
know too much of the details on the bow
but we've got sword both Ornish effect
like apparently a damage over time thing
it sounds like because that's what
Thorne was so specific like if you get
that full like you know the pullback
when you hit that like perfect shot and
that's what does it or what so we'll
just have to see there's also I don't
know why it's called a fusion rifle but
it's an arm launcher basically it's this
thing that basically straps onto your
arm like an arm kind of Mega Man gun
yeah Mega Man solar like ball of
tracking doom believes this it sounds
crazy like I mean if you fire this thing
on a point in control it seems like that
thing's gonna be shut down for a little
while yeah Yoda and the Mega Man cannon
sounds pretty crazy so a large ball of
fire the tracks to your opponent and
leaves a ball of fire on the ground
seems like it's gonna be something
worthwhile to go for what do you think
broken baby I don't know I mean I don't
know how this thing fits in especially
if it's like fusion rifle it may feel
like it's gonna be in an energy category
I'm like dude it sounds like you got
some like wool of a thousand voices feel
going or like this thing's looks like
shout out to Bungie no man when it comes
to weapon design the creativity that
these guys have it's true they truly
don't get enough credit I mean just when
you think you know you like a Mega Man
gun bro like what we have a sniper that
it's like you you you got to give them
credit mandate this so creatively and
and think about all the other great
weapons they've had versus preceding
this and you're gonna continue to pump
out and these are new things too because
I obviously people begin a lot of crap
that is last word and you know the I'm
tired of the old exotics but yeah man
- do it again and they're right up there
with in some and when it comes to
weapons I think they even the past man
when it comes to marketing weapon design
man I mean it is just truly amazing what
they come up with so shout out to those
guys man these these things these levers
look fantastic so those are ones we know
sounds like there's a lot more floating
out there and since we're staring at the
calendar anyway we have an exotic quest
most people seem to know what this is
gonna be spoiler warning and three two
one
say it back it's back baby - word we got
a guest we got preached a good word the
last word did I say that but that was
actually first exotic I ever had really
first is that what ever had was the last
word first one I fell in love with oh
man and just I think it was just all
about that top hand animation of just
flicking right fly fly fly fly hit fight
fight fire the smooth reload it was such
a beast I mean it rang it had a run and
terror and a crucible we all know that
it's it's a then the law behind the gun
you know and how it all tied for we're
gonna get that's what I want is this
question the lover like these are the
ones where it can actually get a reason
behind these guns what is the lore why
is this getting out there what is the
story behind it right make exotics truly
have that feel like if somebody explain
to me the story of how ice breaker
because that seems to be coming up quite
a bit just in general from destiny one
how does it have the function it does
where did it come for how was it built
like how does it regenerate like what is
going on in that damn gun like that wood
because I mean those are little things
like somebody explains like maybe you
take the gun to the black girl and she
said well you go to the forge you build
this like energy cell that you put
inside it's constantly meant like stuff
like that just to understand like guns
like that cuz I mean we're so deep into
these games anyway yeah which is cool to
be like hey you got an exotic
well here's something like here's a
reason behind it not just the lortab
which is cool but like you know how it
came to be that's that's why I'm looking
forward to this so last word quest
or a 29th and so they actually I mean
this is literally the calendar for black
armory we've got a forge on lunch and
three days later we've got another forge
mm-hm you've got something I'll talk
about in a little bit on the seventh as
well yeah literally a week later we have
the dawning starting I don't know how
long that's gonna last two or three
weeks we've got another forge the week
after that two weeks later because
you've got Christmas or three I think
actually for the other forge and you've
got the quest towards the end of January
you've got crimson days coming later I
mean this is outside of Christmas and a
couple times off this is continuous like
padhu's an action-packed man
action-packed can't wait can't wait to
get a hand on the on those different out
forges obviously the draw the huge quest
that did amazing story between the thorn
and the last word the two players
involved you know for those who don't
know the grimoire it's rate it that dad
acts that exactly probably has some of
the best lore in destiny you know though
that whole story and I believe they even
set it up in forsaken when one of the
killers it's Drake yeah exactly so you
know this is great storytelling great
commitment to lore again and it's good
to see like I said they're in pocket
right now they're in Bungie is in pocket
when it comes to content right now have
to give it and it's great to see again
cuz when we started flashpoint you know
how it was so it just feels good to see
them they got the groove right now so
that is most of season forge season of
the forge let's look at the calendar so
you guys can see basically everything we
got season LaForge is December through
February encompass those three months
the dawning will be a thing power
increase we talked about 50 points but
no soft cap just always gonna go up
gonna take that in-game grind new vanity
rewards new rank awards iron banner
triumph lore books crimson days that is
stuff free for everyone and I honestly
like how the power increases free for
everybody if you have forsaken that
power increase just keeps going even if
you don't have the annual pass so if you
do lion banner you're not gonna be left
behind if you knew those like you know
gambit you're not gonna be left behind
when PvP matters like
that's kind of cool that they did that
it's not just attached but your speed to
get there the activities you have those
are more so let me I want to ask you
about that because I think we need to
kind of set that up a little bit more in
the sense of double down on it like this
is new for that right because ultimately
in the past they would always kind of
power gate a non DLC owner yeah I mean
they kind of still do it now with the
old DLC is if you don't know forsaken
you're sucking like 280 or 330 or
whatever right so it's like what do you
feel about it what what do you dick the
approaches with them you know with this
new form of power progression when
people you know hey they don't have they
don't have that content they don't have
annual pass content they're still able
to level up and do stuff I mean I'm a
board like if you've got another point
of forsaken which is what you probably
should be playing if you're playing
destiny like if you got vanilla if you
got the expansions find a way work an
extra shift beg your parents get
forsaken like that is that is the at
least the base that you need to be at
because destiny is not the same game
without that kind of effect the power
boost that you I mean you switched over
to PC that power boost that you got then
got you through that year one that
you're like I really want to do that
good stuff and that's where they want
everybody to be because they know that's
the best this game has ever been and
that's what they want these people jump
in and at so with that being said like
if you go 650 you go 700 more in you
know in the spring and you go 750 over
you know final redacted season everybody
can get to that level now if you don't
have the annual pass it's gonna take you
a little longer because you have less
less to get powerful gear daily still do
your weekly still do your you know your
raids things like that and that's the
one thing we'll kind of cover is like
what's gonna drop it but you still have
your way to get there if you don't do
your a solo player and you work on your
grinds you like your iron banners you
like your gambits you'll start gonna be
on the level playing food filled with
everybody and I think that's the best
thing they could do same with the
crucible Maps because like it doesn't
matter what expansion you have everybody
has the Maps bigger player base for
everybody that's
I'm just about to say you literally took
the words right out of my mouth I think
they'll they're learning that the whole
you know gating is detrimental to that
player base and for them to make that
sort of philosophical change it's a big
deal I think that people are not really
you know stating this more as far as
that I'm glad you said what you said
because like I said like this is gonna
keep if they log in the wave since
forsaken changed every dayi login there
was some type of powerful gear to chase
and attain in some specific activity so
the ad set of people who don't have the
annual pass can stay it'll be slower
yes it's they're not they're not gonna
have all the sources that are you know
the season pass annual pass excuse me
all owners have but they will definitely
um you know find a way to still be able
to kind of slow crawl their way out a
quick question from the dude he said uh
after the dawning he's like sighs he's
going in terms of days after how well
fast over the loss worked out do you
guys think will get Pinnacle weapons
with those event similar to how we got
horror story with festival laws I think
that I mean giving a reason to like
honestly if I did a couple matches or a
couple rounds of the haunted forest if
that grind wasn't there for the six
hundred weapon just to at least check
that box as a collector I didn't get on
the mass but I got a few but that six
hundred weapon just to make sure I had
that one gave me reason to at least play
it longer so I mean those are the things
they I think are starting to understand
we need those incentives because without
them alike I probably would have done a
few rounds played so maybe got one of my
mass leveled up men like yeah that's
kind of cool it's like you know it's a
good base like I like the haunted forest
the concept but you know they could do
more and but I don't feel like I need to
finish it up right now with that six
hundred I did get my 12 rounds in with
randoms even if it is with randoms I got
my twelve rounds and so I get mine and
knock it out so now it does it always
have to be a weapon no but it does need
to be something functional if it's just
a sparrow if it's just a shoe
no no but honestly I think like give us
a sparrow a ship a shake give us some
other stuff as well on each of those and
that just gives us even more time
or if it's tokens for a weapon okay well
once he got that one if you want to keep
going you can get this you know crazy
looking ship or the sparrow or you know
a shader or an ornament or something
like that it doesn't break the game but
I mean something functional for your
character to use yeah I mean I think
that it's gonna make those drawings more
worthwhile personally mm-hmm yeah man I
agree completely man like like this
approach so in the shadows and they're
asking do you think there's gonna be a
special activity alongside the donning
yeah I miss my racing we will we do we
get to the disgorge oh yeah but we ought
we'll talk about that when you but yeah
it's like I don't know if they're always
gonna have an activity maybe they throw
in some I mean you've heard about arms
week at some point that may still fall
in here faction rallies trials there's
still things that are not on this
calendar things can change they know
that but the idea is there's still more
things they can add I don't know if
there's always like crimson days is
gonna have its own PvP stuff that's
literally what it's always been it's
gonna be the twos stuff like that
I hope they tweak that a little more cuz
just the twos still feels like it means
a little love but the dawning I don't
know what the activity would be but man
I really hope they do something yeah
hard like I mean honored forest it made
that was kind of it made sense it makes
sense the infinite forest they could
darken it up have the Halloween theme
cool what do you do for the dawning with
like holidays and yeah that's a good
question I was thinking about that and
silence shadow has me thinking about
that too like you know what do you do
with the dawning you know cuz it really
literally it's a new years for a
generation yes so and it snowballs yeah
I forgot about the cool world oh I like
I like them but I mean they're actually
a lot more fun than I expected for
function but like yeah I was like some I
mean the gameplay piece of that was kind
of cool but I mean maybe it's a snowball
fight maybe it's like a paint ball thing
I don't know the snow you know they can
they have options for everything so it's
possible
but I mean that's all your free stuff so
now you got the Annual Pass
you've got the black armory weapons in
gear which looks like you've got some
cool stuff to grind for we know the
specific ones from the forges we have
the very specific exotic quests which we
know this time is gonna be last word
it's just it's out there sorry spoilers
what it is new triumphs lore books to
work on the forges we know are kind of
gated over time and this is kind of the
thing they want to say mm-hmm things
like iron banner it's here for a week
it's gone it comes back maybe another
month the dawning it is here for two or
three weeks then it's gonna go ahead and
you know then it'll be done for the year
crimson days it's a short term event
when a new forge opens its there for
good it's like adding a new raid option
to your director so if you're like okay
I got this one okay this it forges here
well now the next week I have two forces
I can do like middle of January I'm
gonna have four different forges I can
do on top of a raid another raid in game
activities challenges for the week
dailies Dreaming City shattered I'm like
this is a point where I have too much
crap to do in one game and I'm like how
am I ever gonna go because I really want
to play at them for a place as a PvE
person especially somebody's like maybe
I don't know anybody maybe there's not
matchmaking some stuff I want to do me
doing solo stuff is I'm like built for
that game if it actually feels like it's
gonna fit that so let me tell you right
now what so I got a full disclosure when
Red Dead came out you know when all
these games Kok maybe you can say you're
just a destiny fanatic and I'll eat that
I am that's this is des T's my favorite
game there's no doubt about it but when
destiny is good I cannot sustain playing
anything else for any the extensive bit
of time you know like it was your dude
it was hard for me my dad's amazing in
example when Destiny's good man it's
hard to stop playing and forsaken and
this pattern of content that they going
right now I feel like I'm gonna be
wrapped up in it again he's a great show
he's gotta go to work they stopped by
due back good to see bro good to see
well
yeah destiny his life it is true indeed
it's a full-time job but right now it's
a full-time job again Wednesday you got
this Thursday you got that damn this is
coming and the raids coming the Nats
coming then this events coming ok it's
it's like this calendar it's crazy yeah
I mean there I would they're not even
drip-feeding they're like force feeding
into us it's but a lot of stuff going on
so the other piece yes and they
mentioned it in the viaduct they have a
new raid very specific wording they're
not raid and we have covered the
distinction between the two they say the
red layers were sub sections of a raid
and an area and everything was tied
technically to the Leviathan even though
it was like felt kind of you know
shoehorned in there but this is a new
area separate from anything before not
Leviathan not last wish
this is a completely separately related
experience so is it is its own raid now
is it gonna be last wish with like six
encounters crazy lengths probably not
that long is it gonna be like crota with
like you know two fights and then the
boss at the end somewhere between that
is what they say there is a spectrum of
raids yes they they're feeling like
wrath of the Machine for the action back
in like you've got kind of you know
running gun type moments they even
mention a little bit of like sparrows it
looks like I don't know or a quick path
but yeah you're gonna have to polish up
on your throws you fall behind it might
be an issue I don't know so yeah but it
is based in the lost city so or the last
city I should say so pretty much right
below the tower it's the first time we
really get to go down here outside of
that mission at all mmm-hmm
so it's probably gonna have that palette
that theme but I mean you got buildings
you're in the city and it is called
scourge of the lost past the best
squares of the past sorry yep those
words are the past so is that gonna be I
mean your thoughts man like this is I am
because let me tell you right now I am
so excited for this and I'm not not
saying it's gonna be the best
nor that but from the standpoint of I
know we've had this discussion when
we've ranked raids before but rather the
Machine I'm not saying it's the best
rate but I'm gonna say it's the most fun
rate I've had I love that rate on a lot
of levels it's just a fun fun raid and
to go back to that you know so my close
location yeah it's not the goddamn
Leviathan put your hands together
I'm impressed it's not a Rayleigh I
thought it would be a rail and I would
have been cool with it being a right
list but oh man this sounds really
exciting
I'm definitely um shouts I was that I
was anything like rapid neat I'm so
exactly sell your money great money is
coming let me Rhonda she had the dodge
balls and had fun mechanics like you
know I'm saying like just real cool
things it was very rewarding it just hit
a lot of notes for me on how raids that
I like yours in so that's just for me
way it's not like over mechanical and
over and I think they even said it in
the vid op they made they alluded to the
fact that you know is gonna be some
tension some some high fast action comes
because sometimes you just want to get
in there and shoot some stuff to where
doesn't have to be okay plate see and
I'm on play F and like that everything
has to be a complex algorithm just to
beat it
they took last wish to like a level of
detail and understanding symbols and I
feel like I have to write notes in the
raid and any homework and it's like I'm
saying this is more like understand the
mechanics play it out if you're gonna
have symbols they're gonna be like red
green and blue it's not gonna be like
four different shapes of dragons like
this come on don't get me wrong there's
places for stuff like that I'm glad that
that you know last wish and taking can't
exist the hardcore Raiders raid so to
speak right they want to have their
little algebra calculator and they're
they want to draw their shapes and all
that cool the wrath of the machine is
for me I want to grab see
somehow guys let's jump on spirals in an
Akira looking city like the anime right
the thing it just looks fun look at that
image of scrolling down to that image of
the underneath score score to the pass
we got just down there yeah that image
with the building in that last city like
that doesn't that just it just screams
fun to me like I want to get in that
city I want to do I want to be on the
rooftops you know say like that's what I
want to do in raid you know say so
for me this is definitely a raid I am
super super excited for you know I think
the potential is there you know to be
something special and the last question
I have for you is on the name I thought
was very interesting scourge of the past
but it would work what comes to your
mind when you and you when you hit it
I'm trying to think like I mean I'm
probably blanking on specific either
bosses or like Laura that we're fighting
I mean do you know where they're going
with this one mmm I have no idea I mean
of the vibe I'm getting from the data
miners are falling feel for falling just
because it is the last city and we don't
really get taken or vex like in the city
nobody's really that close so I do think
fallen is gonna be a thing mm-hmm
yeah and I think honestly like we kind
of had the Sivir raid but we've never
truly had a very specific just fallen
raid have way we got it's correct
okay yeah because they day what they
were all taken over what was his name
axis and yeah they were all signified so
yeah mmm-hmm I wouldn't be mad if it
came back but it would be cool to see
some difference who just a regula fallen
situated in a curious thing is what are
they doing they're like what's going on
like yeah why what's going on are they
trying to unlock something is there
somewhere it's a tactic there's a street
on the crest like who knows but I mean
what do you also think on the date three
days yeah we're back to old school
Russian running gun this I guess I'm not
as upset this time only because the
power disparity is not as big as it was
when last wish and forsaken dropped like
we had such a big light jump to try to
get to 600 or whatever it was you know
five whatever you know no arm and the
way it seems that it might be structured
with you know the engrams and priming
grams and power sources I think you know
I think we'll be fine to go from six the
six fifty I mean obviously is probably
entry point what you think it probably
like what I mean every they say it six
forty six forty recommended mmm-hmm
listen I guess the only reason why I'm
giving them a slight pass normally I
would say hey it's too soon but I guess
the reason why I'm giving a slight pass
based on them saying are obviously not a
rate layer but not as big as last wish
so I'm okay am i thrilled no but am I
like tiki torches mad burn the building
down no I'm not there yet but what are
you are you are you burning it down at a
they be messing it up for you but now
I'm not burning it down because I'm
honestly not gonna be a day one reader I
don't have the team I don't have the
like where you got me more the merrier
come on week of it uh spoiler alert
gonna be doing a couple giveaways for a
couple PC copies as well nice they're
coming I got to get my hands on it first
no worries or worry let me know I got
i'll tell attic and accrue make sure
they all into my frag lists all the get
a mob but for me let me think about how
many powerful rewards you can get in
three days so you can dreaming city
you'll have your ascendant challenge
you'll have your powerful wanted bounty
you'll have three daily challenges
you'll have your weeklies but again how
long's that grind when it is just
powerful stuff make that leap - I mean
howhow do you think you're gonna get 615
yeah
it's one
like you're gonna be under level for
this and I think that's what they're
going for that one that's what they want
think about that's what they even said
that belt like the for just to like you
will be underleveled when you start when
you get higher level when you learn the
strats yeah they're gonna get easier but
they want these things to be a challenge
when you start and that makes absolutely
absolutely okay like people are gonna be
doing that go fan and forge first
anything get anything else and then go
into the raid yeah some people will no
no I agree I agree I think so I think
it's just making my decision now that
I'm starting a kindergarten on a PC I
think I might have to go
well irradiance again just because I'm
gonna be so underleveled to try to keep
myself alive and keep everybody else so
yeah I mean that well radiance is huge
helps out your team so even if you're
under you do more for teams and if
you're gone for that endgame stuff
especially in a three-man of people who
don't know what the hell they're doing
especially if you're match made with
idiots
yeah it's gonna happen preach and that's
one of those things what do you I'm
hoping the black forges have the way
they did horror story the way they did a
infinite forest mana for can bong have
the solo option or the match made or non
match made option that's what I want
because shout out to esoteric I know we
talked about him before lose a monster
but by the way guys he's also at 95,000
subs throw a little of his way because I
was following him he just cracked a
hundred thousand subs you know you'll
get your YouTube button so if you can
see Eric I know some of you guys come to
me for solo content and believe me I
appreciate it we have different styles
but the dude that was just a monster at
what he does so yeah go give him a
little love if you haven't subbed to his
channel I want to see him get a hundred
thousand as well I just wanted to send
that out the universe guy so yeah he's a
beast just crushes it so he's on facts
but somebody like him like and somebody
like me it's like I want to go challenge
myself and see if I can solo one of
these I don't even know if it's possible
no it's probably not but if it is or
isn't you know see if it is like give
those people that option if you only see
if you only match make you take away
that solo queue and it's just nice to
it'll I just hope they give you the
option that's all I'm gonna open for mmm
sorry I had a window over I think I
missed like mine
your chat in here and twitch I'll catch
up guys in a second no worries
so season two season four
I'm sorry season six mm-hmm season the
drifter I want you to break down this
next one give me a second to catch up on
my chat here so give us a little of what
do we got for Season Of The Drifter all
right the drifter so it looks like and
now as far as you just want me to break
down from the updates of the Annual Pass
content I'm just gonna go through what
we're getting same thing I did um yeah
it looks like cuz oh so we got gambit
extended upon private matches and new
maps Oh private matches huge deal um we
have another exotic quest we have a
spring event we've got power increase
which is to be expected new triumphs and
Lord looks new vanity rewards
interesting new rank rewards I am banner
so those are that's pretty much the crux
of it however let's see we gotta oh we
got more with the content obviously I
know but the Joker's wild weapons in
gear so I'm curious about that another
excites
new trifle of books new gambit
experience hmm
curious but that's a question know
something that warmed my heart at the
but I lost my mind when I saw this one
oh this is what you were talking about
picked us out of the killer full
disclosure
um he boxes text me when this kind of
came out and maybe my head was just I
was doing too much I was like what is he
so excited I think you're gonna know it
when you see it I'm sitting and I'm like
it's not so bad we actually got together
and I'm like oh yeah this is what he was
like what of oh I don't know why I guess
it was so many icons with the screen
that's something wrapped going on I
understand but I was just like you also
didn't like you you didn't read between
the lines cuz I was like how are you not
seeing this we've only been talking
about this like six months now you know
what it was I was so excited about new
raid in season of the forge over a raid
lair oh come on be honest you're excited
about PC master-race get on board well
of course that too
I gotta follow my brother my brother I
gotta follow but um you know at the end
of the day I'm just like when I now I'm
reading I'm glad you made me read this
I'm like sir our good friend boy have
you been useless prior to this point so
this is exciting
sir bow knees let's see what that is I
will let you take that and then joke is
well a weekly quest I'll let you take
that go for it man this is which this is
all you now well first I mean up at the
top we got private matches and new maps
for gambit which is gonna be awesome cuz
I mean right now you have a lot of
variety a different weapon type not
different but different enemy types and
for maps and then we got a fifth one
with their doorway are we up to four
with the dream you said e1 I can't
remember because you have this like
steampunk like that one you got dreaming
city
you got the necess one missing and then
you have the four so yeah there are four
or so three or four new game it Maps
like the mode always feels this is one
of the things like crucible maps like
everyman choice feels a little different
but gambit has like the different
enemies so honestly it tends to feel
different so don't focus on the map as
much but if you throw more variety in
there as well I mean just the more the
merrier so mm-hmm
I can't wait for that and just private
matches if people want to do gambit
tournaments that's a way for them to do
it I don't ever do much of the private
matches because they're not custom
matches and that's the difference if
they ever get to the point lettuce
custom match and be like hey auto rifles
are ten thousand percent damage and you
just like most stuff over stuff dies
insanely fast you just totally break the
game for a little while that's what I
still would ever love but we're not
gonna get there it seems for half but
I'm down for that power increases come
in vanity rewards exotic quest number
two than this now here's the distinction
there's one exotic quest for every one
quest
only being in the annual pass for two of
these things what do you think um you
know man will be a little bit of latest
on this hey listen
you lucky to be here at the power level
you at what I'll listen yo said dudes
dude that commit I'm I'm with it I'm
listen it's not as an exclusive VIP club
as it was in the past where they can't
attain power levels but if guys are
paying for that annual past content they
should be rewarded with extra things so
this to me is I'm not I don't you know I
can't see people like oh I'm being
locked down as part of the past it's
part of our annual pass you know other
games do it I don't see the issue so I
have I have no problem and look you're
getting an exotic quest they're getting
still damnit private matches they're
still getting a lot of stuff they're
like they're not getting anything that
that pretty but put it this way that
disparity could be greater if Bungie
really wanted to yeah I mean and it
could I think Bungie probably fought
hard to keep it at this level to keep as
much inclusion as possible because you
see like everyone gets the Maps not just
the new people it's like weapons gear
certain things fine like that's gonna be
part of the expansion of that little
piece of content for the annual pass but
the maps you can level up you can play
all the maps you can still fight all the
enemies you're just gonna be doing it
with different guns that's basically how
you can describe it like you'll be
fighting them with different gear but
you still can fight all the same stuff
which is cool like I kind of like that
so exotic quest spring event any
thoughts I don't have a damn clue yeah
Wes we're gonna have an icon for it cuz
I'm not gonna do you think they bring
what was it not agent is a drive well no
that was age of triumph was like the end
of d1 Soulstice of here's what we did
last year and that's coming in the next
one mmm so I really don't know what this
is no I don't know maybe one if any if
any time spiral racing got a shot that
would be attack be like a doubt of a
Down moment in between so and you'll
pass it we got the with new weapons in
gear so that'll be I don't know if
there's like quests for these if there's
a little story behind the drifter but
basically they describe this is your
time to learn about the drifter what's
you doing
straight what is going on is he good is
he bad I have no clue I don't honestly
think he nobody trusts the guy cuz we're
he I can get him energy and he thinks us
for it like he's got these like you know
crazy dude off to the side be like hey
thanks you got any more that take a
ninja like there's some there's some
reason for that yeah he's missed them
and obviously you know with the whole
malfeasance quest I believe as well they
can expound a little bit on that you
know he's definitely flirtin with
something with that whole you know dark
and evil line so long yeah we I'm
actually curious about him and then
obviously the connection decayed you
know if you do Kade story the ice faith
quest you know he mentions only mentions
how they drifter was actually I mean
Gambia it was actually Jade's idea it
was this so those two had a relational
disappointed at when Kate passed
sidetrack right now that when Kade past
that drifters didn't really seem that a
you know empathetic he's like oh you
lost your buddy your buddy went down oh
my dude it was your buddy Joe he said it
in your will so I'm like a little so I'm
very curious about us you know diving
deeper into the did drifter lore see
what's going on with this cat we've got
another exotic quest for annual pass
people don't know I don't have a clue on
these Joker's wild weekly quest no now
it's this weekly quest not challenge not
activity quest which is weird
terminology to me I'm sitting there
actually kind of racking it through my
brain I like right now to go like you
know those literally say over here like
black armor gear forges weekly activity
like that stuff weekly quest is just an
oddball way to phrase that thing I don't
know why I don't know if it's like if
it's just like a do you think there's
gonna be like separate weekly quests
that are gonna be like different things
do you think there's maybe some
voiceover lines to them is it just like
a weekly thing that you keep repeating I
don't know the activity and weird
terminology but it doesn't they're
usually very choice about their words
that's why it's a little hard to me no
idea the only thing I'm gonna say about
this whole
content with season a drifter this thing
had a lot of potential to be great but
we also have to talk about the elephant
in the room
there is no raid or raid lair on that
pass nope
so they in my opinion have to really
come with the content and whatever
endgame event is and whatever spend me
that is spring event maybe you know
they've got to really do something to
distract us similar to I would say arm
like a prison of elders Lord of was a
house of wolves kind of deal when house
didn't have that theoretical raid but
they had some other molds and stuff like
that checkers and the elders yeah and
I'm saying so maybe they're gonna have
to find something in game wise that's
the only thing I'm worried about cuz
obviously that DLC doesn't have any type
of rate associated yeah and honestly
maybe that's them just saying hey gamuts
this thing you can jump in play some
rounds work on your grinds things like
that you'll have some xur bounties which
is I am honestly so curious what they're
gonna do these are there gonna be exotic
quest are they different things for like
we've said zero bound ease just to get
like what do they called now enhancement
corns yes enhancement cores you know I
was going all those types of things I
don't know what sir bounties are gonna
do but also maybe this is them just
literally looking at marketing going
anthem is February 22nd wrap up the
season the forge division to is March
let this downtime be the time when
they're like doing hey here's this you
know come play gambit sometimes do these
rounds easy grinds not quite as crazy
build your hype back up in June July and
August with the new raid with the
redacted with all the discovery and
secrets that make people go insane about
this game to me the season of drifter
it's that downtime when you're gonna
have people come back for quest here
here's an exotic quest like smaller this
is your drip-feed time where there's
gonna be some things but this will be
the low-key part I think I'm the annual
past all right that's what I'm calling
it now yeah definitely definitely
so but yeah I mean it's there will there
doesn't look like much in-game was it
Jimbo and your chat saying like
thunderlord was a weekly quest maybe it
is something like that maybe are there
maybe that's like little pieces of stuff
like that maybe there's ways they do it
I don't know but I mean I do think this
will be the low key of the three for
sure yeah I agree I think I think he
nailed nailed it with that so can we've
kind of speculated before but a new
gambit experience
I mean gambit is a whole new experience
anyway what's a new version of that I am
very curious about that that's what I
want to see I'm very curious what that
means like cuz gambit play different
like what that mean it does I don't get
the vibe that is just new maps like I
get the big they're changing something
fundamentally or adding some things so
Lucy yeah I'm Sam yeah that's yeah
that's like the grind we'll be there
we'll have more stuff to grind as we go
but I mean I wonder how like if they do
Pinnacle weapons every season that's
that's a lot of stuff to start grinding
for definitely keeping you busy so uh uh
so that is season drifter maybe a little
more low-key but still some exotic
quests you'll want to jump back in for
occasionally see what the Joker's wild
is season of the blank the deck day
season of I've heard this is called
season of the shadow mmm I have no idea
what but it would make sense well
they've been should they call this
penumbra as yes he's a number literally
relates to the shadow and the phases of
the Sun of the Moon and stuff like that
so if you don't look at the definition I
don't know the specific one but it's
related to that the season that shadow
makes a lot of sense mm-hmm but it's
also the way they describe it and I I
really hope they kind of do what I'm
about to say because if they do this
will build your height back in the world
of destiny because it's after things
have been out its before that September
insanity lunch of all the games in the
fall and this is that perfect time when
there's not a lot to do over the summer
season of the blink they do no marketing
just say it's live go dig what quests
are out there what's new you like you
want to see people like dive in the game
be like what's over here what's in this
corner of the world like where's this
what are the new and like everybody
looks for all the new stuff in the world
you just gonna be discovery constantly
like not here's this new raid you don't
even know where it's at like just
literally as things are found stuff
keeps getting like trickled in or this
new quest comes this week if they
don't tell us anything some of the times
when destiny is the best when you don't
know you don't know he like what like I
said those whispered of our moments
those like they're like those are the
things that make destiny destiny I mean
so I'm hoping I mean they've got
redacted redacted new weapons and gear
now this is cool
a new six player match made activity
collar let's go let's go learn from
escalation protocol man let's go love it
that's what I'm talking about that's
what I'm talking about you got to do
that man you have to be inclusive you
have this great game with all this great
content and people want to play together
how do you meet new people like these
are the type of things you got to do it
man mm-hmm mm-hmm sorry I'm trying to
curtail somebody in your yeah that's
gone thank you thank you scream damn it
scream anyway but yeah it's like a
6-point match-made activity if it's a
big thing like if it's out there just as
like maybe it is an escalation maybe
they use patrol zones and do something
like bigger events in hell yeah
like I mean this is what we've all been
waiting for because matchmaking having
the option is just what everybody wants
you don't always want to but if you
don't have the option so many people
miss out on content which is the
struggle like the rain is a hard thing
for still like 80% of the playerbase to
get into shattered thrown unless you're
gonna go bash your head against the solo
which I'm gonna do this weekend because
I still want my freaking numb [ __ ]
thanks not everybody as dumb as I am
most you guys are smarter and you're not
gonna spend your time on that having
random people to get through stuff with
yeah there's probably gonna be some
mechanics in there but I mean yeah they
they the option needs to be there more
frequently or not just to actually let
people come through mm-hmm so and
another raid yes Sam Cluett and they say
raid again specifically not raid lately
yeah no we know what it is though
eluded everything again seems like
towards Bulova a son usually this is
that I think it's all gonna link in to
UM you know the whole penumbra the whole
you know what that's behind and I have
my theories you know obviously without
cow Callas hinting at other things
possibly
being greater when I see sees another
redacted I see that robot it just
screams Benedict to me yeah you know
looking like a beast ninja with a sword
on it look for him by the way like a
robot with a ninja sword I'm like oh
damn mm-hmm yeah mess so I mean III
think that we we get probably the
conclusion that we deserved you know at
after because I thought leviathans
conclusion wasn't fine
I'm just talk about like eater of worlds
inspire was like what the hell is going
on
no you know I'm saying never technically
fought cat like yeah yeah so maybe him
maybe we get to a different section so
maybe that's and they say season of the
shadow I mean we had the cinematic were
you know the travelers energy went out
into the world and we've been
progressing through all of these pieces
or you know at first a touch mercury and
it touched Mars then we're in the reef
like this cinematic has been this giant
plan that they've had in yes and the big
black diamond space Torito ships that
might honestly be the thing that this
leads into and this is where all of this
hopefully will make me come together so
mmhmm yeah I don't know if all of you
guys in chat look at this and if you
tell me if it's worth thirty five
dollars or not that's up to you you can
do freebie you can live in the forsaken
world still be 750 by the time it comes
and you can still get your Soulstice of
heroes but maybe which may bump you know
like hey you're gonna be seven seventy
seven eighty come whatever comes in the
fall or you can pay thirty five bucks
and have all this new stuff to do to me
couple raids the forges the ZURB
bounties which are weird that they're
specific the serve bounties they annual
pass I'm not sure how they're gonna
distinction those but couple exotic
quest new I mean
it I feel like the other you have other
games like you know Call of Duty you'll
get Maps you'll have you know you'll
have some story things here you're gonna
have story you're gonna have maps you're
gonna have gambit experiences raids all
this stuff and for all they're asking
for a full year like they're not even
asking for a subscription model right
now which is honestly something that
they could do and I would be okay with
coming from world of warcraft be like
you want to pay ten bucks a month pay
120 bucks a year I'd do it in a
heartbeat
a little screams of what you you were
talking about last flashpoint they say
that literally yes this is what you were
talking about is you'e preaching this
this consistent content that you almost
paid a subscription price for and it
literally feels like that's exactly what
they're doing but in a you know console
way I mean that constantly but in a
different kind of a way but that's a
little bit less you know um intrusive
yeah so I mean it's 35 bucks it's like I
mean it's not even five bucks a month
for the time that we're not and like for
these seasons you break 30 bucks it's
ten dollars a season it's like you know
thirty dollars a month I think you
cannot have a cup of coffee like it's an
easy thing to justify so to me yeah you
can make all me a destiny shell or
whatever I mean that's fine but to me
the value of the content that we're
getting in a game with so many different
activities to me is very very worth it
so how much you've had right I mean look
how much it look how many hours the
content has given us so it's like the
the value proposition has more than paid
for itself you know in my opinion so I
completely agree with you completely
yeah and then there's stuff we haven't
even mentioned in you got me set it to
think about surprises they haven't even
put on the calendar whisper type
missions that just show up they mention
they mentioned people love those things
that whisper clear is part of it the
shattered throne we don't have a mention
of another dungeon in here hahaha
I mean give you another dungeon
somewhere in here and I'll buy the day
manual pass for literally that alone is
going so much because it is like the
perfect level of guy can solo it's a
three-person thing you don't need a raid
it's doable but the mechanics the
challenge like it
managers oh yeah so they won me at two
new rates nitrate layers sir ponies and
um six player match made activity right
we still got two redacted that we don't
even know what those are and nobody has
a freaking clue so yeah man yeah it's
like we might at some point get trials
that'll be for everybody you might some
point get back generalities that's still
for everybody so I mean they're gonna
bait honestly shoutout to those guys cuz
they're seriously kicking that
everything's bought right now because
what they're doing in like the
production the amount of work those guys
are putting in if I could shake all of
their hands all of them like big guys
small guys the artists like I mean we're
gonna get whatever new rate is skybox on
the new rate I'm still gonna take that
second look up and be like whoever did
this guy locks you crushed it like that
thought still goes through my head is
it's amazing
so I mean bunchy still puts in great
work activision may have its thoughts
and otherwise but bunchy still wants to
make this game for us and i think that's
one of the best things they do
agreed killing it right now they are so
that pretty much covers it this week at
Bungie kind of basically tapped on
everything you've got the black armory
calendar they mention a little bit lower
down here again go watch the Vidak just
really cool there's a little there's a
few things you'll see in there if you
want spoilers and things nothing too
crazy that we haven't talked about in
here so if you guys made it this long
our spoilers but much the calendars in
there here's where they talk about
scourge of the past I mean they do say
it doesn't fit the definition of a raid
layer because it's not an extension of a
current rate it isn't it is its own
it may not be six pieces like last wish
but it's somewhere between the big and
the small it is it's raid you know three
to four encounters and still pretty cool
and this is your high def picture this
is your picture of the raid yeah baby
I'm just say that you know what ate the
first world it was so fire was like I
said they had you on sparrows in the
city on some makeer of
I'm already in then this bat looks like
rats in the machine meets a carat weight
with some secret we gotta see what's
going on down there
oh I'm high I'm excited I'm gonna get
back to a fun read less mechanically
less you know there's gonna be some
mechanics of course but um you know less
you know that hardcore thing that we
were talking about with a last mission
and taking and just more more of a fun
vibe and based on a video that's the
vibe I'm getting this is definitely a
fun breakneck high intensity high
action-packed let's get it you know so
yeah that's the image man that's the
image right there got me - re and it's
not a rate layer like King is in a jet
you stick it out for a leg cramp that's
John okay yeah it will launch Friday
daily reset recommended power 640 so but
there's no minimum so I'm going to here
602 you can jump in you may get smashed
in the face by the first guy you see but
you get a look your one shot bar a drink
just like tapi on the shoulder and be
like yeah you can die now mm-hmm or
honestly they'll just be like down there
doing what they do they'd be hiding
behind buildings and doing those like
grenade throws like just just clutch
just you know throwing darts out there
with those grenades honestly I joke in
my videos I probably said it before I
want to go to drag grenade school
because school because like grenades man
from enemies grenades are like just
lethal mm-hmm yeah and then we got our
number 650 power progression it's
official stopgap saves at 500 now
players under 550 you should expect to
see prime engrams more frequently so a
quicker boost to get ups a closer and
receive higher bumps from the priming
grams and so they're gonna help like if
you're jumping a little later you're
leveling up that extra character it's
not gonna be quite the grind it was up
to a point and then it'll slow down but
I think in general kind of a nice way to
balance it out not not just send you
straight like a rocket ship to 600 even
out even out some of that in between
absolutely cool that
and also for those of you guys who have
been playing forsaken since it started
finally getting our veterans bundle on
December 18th
we got the unique shaker and of this
tiger-stripe one we've got the in bloom
that goes with it which always looks
cool
a bundle of a whole bunch of stuff I'm
kind of curious how much that's gonna be
some pretty damn cool emotes you got the
coin it was it like these are cool coin
flip just flipping it over easy got that
one and then just throw the knife haha
shout out to my boy you know who'd ask
for oh yeah
but it's there the neon emotes which are
the ones I like they're not just to
dance they're the ones that have a
little more tune so I'm glad these are
cool and if you played cool you get them
if you didn't play at that point still
just the cosmetic but I think for those
who did
they're honestly pretty cool and again
look in the back behind these are the
images they're staining in the black
armory so if you want to dig a little
deeper look behind these little gifts
they're there but yeah so destiny update
two point one point one comes on Tuesday
December 4th mmm not too much downtime
they say just about half an hour so I
think we probably downloaded most of the
content already yes let's be here so
this will be the kind of activation of
everything else you're gonna have your
first forge go live amongst everything
else and the raids three days later so
hit the ground running grant I'm back at
it there's a few things that they know
about some there are some guns that are
dropping right now if you guys haven't
seen them there's a few saboteurs for
Mike Ford stuff tours out in the world
they can drop some weapons right now
from black armory and some people are
seeing double perks that are weird so I
mean there's a couple things that are
broken right now just just wait a few
days they got it all in check coming
soon most of it is gonna be alright so
and that's pretty much a wrap and shout
out again movie the week by the way just
cuz this is insane
pestered petra's run is a no death by
anyone not res no death by anyone raid
run that is how
have to do it and they threw me on the
whole damn thing mmm yeah sick man oh I
know we at the end we didn't touch that
uh get in there okay I'll make sure that
we didn't forget it was gonna be a giant
spoiler alarm gonna have to say it so
that one's cool and then just a nice
thunderlord video looks like yeah
rocking out to it but in general even
just this little gift somebody did
school because somebody sits down then a
guy turns around the chair comes up next
to him which is perfectly placed and
then this guy over here lights as little
basically thing yeah if you want to
avoid spoilers go I don't know if
anybody has seen will help scream has
seen it you know and he promptly deleted
his uh comet you don't want spoilers for
anything come in a black arm or
especially any story related stuff
because there may not be that much now
is the time to duck out you guys can
wait so you getting it for most of our
cast that's why we're saving it for the
end but there's one more piece to this
whole little stuff that's happened
lately and so we're gonna do this in 10
seconds
you have 9 seconds to leave 8 7 6 5 4 3
2 one final spoiler warning coming up if
you ain't here this is your business now
you know what you live for
okay so you want to say it or me so um
shout out to Eurogamer who I was just
looking casually you know no destiny
information I believe um Bungie put out
a tweet and then it was separate and
then PlayStation put out a tweet but
that was separate all khana vintage
vadhaka kind of stuff but then Eurogamer
in that same case happened to have a
destiny black Armory article I'm like
cool you know I'm saying let's learn
what we need to learn you know find out
information I'm scrolling down on my
artists is cool information this is
great and then they start with a spoiler
warning
and I'm like and I don't know where they
got the source from but there is an
video there's a small video and you
pretty much watch it you throw it on and
from what it seems to me I'm just gonna
give you my assessment of what I felt
and what I saw
so it looks like you know the camera
pans in we're back at the Dreaming city
the Dreaming city looked cleansed I'm
gonna say it looked clean or maybe just
a cycle at that time was the normal
cycle yeah and there is kind of like a
slab and almost like a memoriam and
obviously there's a body there's a sheet
over the body so I'm lucky interesting
okay and then a ghost appears and
proceeds to go to the body skin the body
I'm okay all right where's just going
and she comes off and almost like a game
of Thrones moment with a boy Jon Snow
yeah it was literally a Jon Snow moment
and come to find out oh boy Aldrin is
back yeah I'm gonna let you take this
from now and what is your assessment of
this said video so I had caught like a
blip and I saw it and then as soon as
you said it I knew what you were talking
about because I had seen that little I'd
seen the face I haven't seen the full
video oh but I've seen who it was I knew
as soon as you're like holy have you I'm
like I'm 99% sure I know what you're
talking about because that's the only
thing that would be that big but I had
like kind of seen it and almost
disregarded but as soon as you said it I
was like okay it's real and basically
what did you look at shadow cast by the
altar looks like someone else's head
I'll have to go watch again look watch
it again yeah
to watch it again for that but the
concept that you have to remember how
did we become a
talk about it you see in destiny one or
out and if you guys did the fundable
request you saw this area and it was
literally like the Cosmodrome
by the wall ghost is floating around and
then BAM it puffs up it pulses up gets
this energy blasts in and wakes us up in
the exact same manner as it does open so
debate what are you implying what are
you implying Yvonne TISS as the traveler
chosen Aldrin to be a guardian
that is the question now is really what
I want life to be on here yes sure he
would have a better answer but I mean
the idea is the ghosts choose who to
wake up and when they choose you your
ghost I mean your ghost is how you're a
guardian and that is how you get to come
back that is all those pieces so now a
ghost woke him up and they choose they
look I mean it's like I look forever
like when it wakes us up it's like I
looked forever for you
I looked ears like I never thought I
would find you and then it did what does
this mean now scream he's talking about
some shadow scream so just say what it
is right now just say whatever this
shadow is we black or see just implying
that like there is a guardian with them
that scans and like wakes them up um but
here's the day yeah scream jumping I'm
comments cuz I'm curious to know what
you talk about this shadow like I'm with
you II like I think the vibe I got is
that you know he was killed at the end
of a second we know that mmm that's been
resurrected as a guardian a will wha
Kate's head hold on I you see that part
yeah he said did you see the shadow cast
I don't know man I mean listen if they
do that that's I might have a problem
with that
all right so hold on that's another
that's another thing we're gonna take
this slow so if you guys haven't seen it
yet and granted we just blow the living
crap out of it but this is one place for
it
this is in PG 27 eurogamer's got the
same thing so it's in my twitch boiler
warning links here as well we
cutscene fullscreen we're gonna play it
slow and pause so everybody get ready
here we go
interesting
so there's a ghost looking around now
the ghost looks alone usually they're
not too far from their Guardians right
seems to be on its own here's the
memorial we're talking about dreaming
city looking very nice so here's the
post you got sunlight you've got leaves
blowing through and you have that
memorial you have the kind of cloth over
the top you know kind of that respectful
yeah
covering mm-hmm now there's no audio on
this one so which I guess who buries the
guy in cloth he was gonna start smelling
so left him out there like that but so
right now you scream keeps talking about
shadows and if you guys are catching
like oh oh yes I see a shadow he said
yeah but I think this is just the shadow
of this this is alright looks like right
now
dulann watch the shadow a little later
okay so here like it's scanning scanning
scanning and then this moment right here
that that is the fact that that Ghost is
like using its energy from the traveler
to do something do something
mm-hmm wait and they're sheep energized
electricity all that good stuff
mmm raised on up and bam Aryan he's like
holy crap the dude's alive mm-hmm he's
like how am i alive what happened mm-hmm
he's still here Knight doesn't like
smile or anything so he's not like
sinister but the dude is the dude is up
now as if I can find that shadow point
where screams talking about he's looking
at here basically yes looks like the
face shape of Kay's hey I know that's
what he was talking about I mean I to me
I'm just in the lighting I think it's
more just like either the feet catching
the shadow the feet here catch and then
just this little bump of his head goes
off for
so [ __ ] a little raised up is my
assumption so I think that's that maybe
it is a throwback cuz yeah it does look
like Kay did with this little spire I'm
just thinkin to be honest I don't think
yeah okay being alive that's just me
personally and to be honest I'm gonna
jump in right now I think it would is
gonna piss a lot of people oh I think
it's a travesty to still bring to bring
Kaede back now I know people gonna say
hey what you gonna bring his enemy back
and that's disrespectful guy that killed
his day let's be real according to law
for those who have played the game and
the story you know Aldred yeah he was
messed up but everything he did he
thought he was doing the right thing
Yeah right Lorelei's he thought he had
to do that and he was being manipulated
which was every big so and according to
like his past law he was beloved you
know and I'm saying in that city and and
he anything that had to do with the
Queen he was right by our side so you
know we have to keep that in mind and
then you have the taken factor you have
the riven factor right you have the
Sabbath on behind the scenes factor you
know I'm saying so we have all these
things and a man that is clearly being
manipulated does what he thinks right
which is completely wrong he meets his
fate he dies so violet now implies you
know there's repercussions whatever now
here's the big like you said you know
you have a ghost right the only time we
she goes do this is really selecting the
Guardian so when did they feel is worthy
clearly the traveler has made a decision
this is what I get out of it you know
said I'm the traveler has said that he
is going to be needed he is powerful
enough that that's part of the whole
Guardians law I mean that these guys are
needed for the ultimate battle against
the darkness so how ironic is this and
what makes it I think even cool and I
want to talk about it would be the
ultimate kind of redemption story the
last point I will say how funny and
weird it out now do we know
if I even say this point do we know um
what aldrin classes are we gonna assume
he's winter do you got - yeah yeah I
think you're headed where Chronos
mentioned it and Chad and I think I know
where you're going um let's say
obviously he's ve beat you to it
let's get Colonel Sam so basically what
he's saying is when you do cayde-6 is no
yes they're his dere he's like it's one
of those like you know the best bet I
ever lost or whatever he talks about
like Guardian killed him they would
become the new hunter Vanguard ding ding
ding ding ding ding
as a newly resurrected Guardian it could
mean that Aldrin is capable of being the
vanguard now I don't know what a
guardian does when it pulls you out
because it feels like as a guardian we
have no history we don't know who we
were before we don't know what we did in
the past act so if it's late give me
work I'm actually watching blind spot
with my wife wipe type situation is it a
point to where like he could be someone
good
but cans cans of Allah can they accept
me I Cora look at him and not just want
to that's why this is great storytelling
and I want to give credit to Bungie on
this because I know a lot of Cape as
maybe pissed but this is great drama
this is great theater because like you
said it been long which if he's right he
doesn't know he's old he doesn't know he
did all this big he is awake just like
we are awake he is a real woke and he's
resurrected to come back and how I was
talking to ematic about that I was like
how crazy would it be that Aldrich is
the new vague or and we still don't have
a replacement right no we don't and
that's why we've all been wondering like
I think this is fantastic story and
what's crazy is I came into black armory
thinking it wasn't gonna be much
storytelling that there wasn't gonna be
um say like doom scream as high or
higher to be like hey this is the
evolution of bungy storytelling we never
get twists like this we never get this
depth in storytelling and I'm proud I'm
proud of me I don't know how they got
ahold of this
I don't know that question is watches do
you think this is at the start of
backyard this is when you beat black
armory like what do you think the
timeline is like I don't know I mean if
it's a cinematic that exists I feel like
because I mean screams and Chet
mentioning like season of the shadow I
don't think you can be that far because
I don't think we'd even have it yet
right I mean if it's data mined or
ripped out of like whatever the new
files war with the patch and stuff like
that if that's where it came from
I think it has to be this season I don't
know if it's now I don't know if it
comes with that you know last word quest
something related to like hunters and
all those pieces like I don't know where
it falls but I feel like it has to be
this season I just don't know if it's
gonna be related to the story or if it's
like the ultimate quest cinematic and
just like holy mother of what just
happened yes is this is deep on so many
levels then we have the more Asaf
relationship mmm how is that now changed
he you know I'm saying don't even know
does he even know you know say like it
is that the the top just the scene in
the tower alone if he used to return
there only it could be like the shame
moment in Game of Thrones
but that's what it's like I don't know
and this is one of those things where I
almost want to like tweak one of the you
know my Lander wife and say like do
guardians when you're resurrector to
have any like any inclination or can you
ever have an idea of what was done in
your past like are you killed are you
resurrected as a guardian and you have
no history because you stick by playing
of all of this game so far for four
years and how long it's been
I've never known that my guardian has a
past I know that I have my Guardians
start date from like day 0 and record he
is a day 0 Guardian he knows nothing of
his former life now we do and the
interactions and the reactions to him
are going to be quite interesting but
yeah like he I'm with you that's what a
guardian is resurrected that's how he
comes back no history no past history
this is yeah man childish gave me said
EXO seemed to somewhat yeah this is this
is very interesting man and I was very
surprised that they did this but kudos
to them I'm very curious to see where
this goes this blew my mind when I saw
my texture immediately I do
oh what a crazy twist let a crazy twist
yeah so I mean I have no idea what this
means but I mean you guys are still here
at least half the chat is so you guys
want to talk about this I mean it's just
like they can do so many things with it
so now we just got to see if Bungie
really gets back to using their writers
and the story to make like is this gonna
be this like long arcing connection
through forsaken that connects the next
September is this the thing that builds
into the shadow is there you gonna be
part of the vanguard is he getting
fighting alongside Zavala yeah I mean
what if vol it makes his bubble and like
Nascar yeah I mean come on the dude is
they mentioned that the way they're
handling content is a continual story
mmm I mention that Nevada
you know they've so this whole thing to
see how this plays out oh good job good
job
you know maybe necessary I'm you know
didn't expect to see anything like this
so early you know Sam but um I can't
wait to see how this thing unfold I
think they're going into fantastic
direction if all this is true yeah so on
that bombshell
no I'm stealing that from top gear like
it's I mean this is a long point we knew
it would be we had a lot of chat coming
up on like 2 and 1/2 hours I know you're
gonna pass out honestly it's been
awesome morning so I think that's pretty
much all we've got for at least today
but if that's not enough d'azyr's gonna
be up in about 42 minutes so that'll be
coming we've got black armor here on the
corner we got forges and forges and raid
layers and quests and so much stuff to
do so it continues to be a great time to
play destiny to me biased or not I feel
like they so far I said there had to be
a lot of weight to this to this piece of
the annual pass the
for just how cool their match made we
have a full new lair
we've got new weapons things like that
in game grind is gonna be there and if
the story is there's anything related to
this image on screen right now I'm gonna
be pretty cool so they've made a good
step and if they keep it up man I'm I'm
gonna be happy I think this season the
dirt will have that kind of quieter time
with activities to do but not that push
while other games are being out there
and then finish it up with whatever is
gonna tie into season of the reductant
so mm-hmm
I think we've taken up enough of your
time this morning guys but if you want
to wrap it up kognito you can do it
first yeah man look it's fantastic to be
back in man shout to the chat everybody
say shout the scream everybody checks a
bull fence has Chronos everybody today
man good to be back after the holiday
talking destiny again exciting time so
much good stuff and you know for me man
it's the same thing on Lords podcast you
already know every Sunday is the Lord's
Day you can catch me there at 11 a.m.
Eastern Standard Time will have Bratt
podcast on a returning friend of the
realm talking gaming all the latest
craziness with Bethesda all these great
topics we got to discuss man we may have
a couple of surprises as well so tune in
on the island podcast YouTube channels
from that and I believe also fight talk
comment talk with the king there's a big
fight coming up to Saturday he's gonna
have some content for that as well so
check that out and of course flashpoint
Fridays for my man
Ibaka snotty a.m. Eastern Standard Time
good to be back brother back in the seat
and playing destiny with you finally not
only take forever doing a podcast I'd
never played there's a period of great
kind of insane now we can finally cross
that off our checklist so thanks ah same
with me as well guys sir will be up as
soon as it goes live here in about 40
minutes I'll get that one up for you
guys gonna be working on shattered
throne solo this weekend I have to
finish that one just because I got
through to granted my way through so
that is gonna be my feet for this
weekend I might be streaming some of
them might get the videos up but that is
my goal but you guys can find me on
Twitch or Twitter so let me have you
guys on Twitch already see voluntas on
both of those but on youtube i'm like 30
subs away from 27,000 so keep that train
going you
guys are awesome so it's been a great
day it's Friday the weekends here enjoy
your weekend go see a movie have some
good food have some fun playing destiny
and we got a lot to do coming up so stay
tuned guys the next weeks also gonna be
crazy interesting because the raids
gonna go live basically after we finish
we'll have one Forge under our belt
yeah so keep it going guys you're rock
stars and we thank you for all the
support you guys are great so we'll see
you soon sub hype follow iron Lords
podcast follow uh mine as well
just hate us all up and we'll see you
guys in the next one peace have a good
one
see you soon guys